so Glenn Beck tweeted out earlier that
apple had removed all of his shows don't
worry briefly they were down but now
they're back and apple says it was one
big mistake but I really doubt it I'm
willing to bet it was a rogue employee
who is fervent and anti-trump and far
left who probably took down his podcast
or it was a top-down effort to put a
little fear into those who would speak
out Against the Machine
as we enter 2024 you know things are
going to get very spicy when it comes to
censorship and already we have a ton of
super chats before the show even started
of people saying they're struggling to
find this show well yeah election season
is upon us and so it's going to become
increasingly difficult to find our Clips
our show Etc so if you like the show and
you want to push back take the URL right
now post it wherever you can don't let
them try to throttle and suppress us or
anyone else but we'll talk about that as
we start entering this election season
we got a lot of news pertaining to
what's going on there's uh more talk
about what's going to happen with Donald
Trump his personnel and his lawyers as
they're ordered to surrender they're
going to be placed in County Jail which
will be a site it's going to be very
interesting as to how the Secret Service
actually negotiates this and there's a
lot of questions about whether Trump
actually can be charged for things he
did as president under the Constitution
and then we've got more polls
Swami is uh in second place and many of
these polls in an interview he actually
mentioned that if Trump were to be
removed he could be the front runner he
didn't say that as something good he
said it was a bad thing that he needs to
actually earn the trust of people and
win honorably but they could you know it
would serve him to have Trump removed
because he in some in some instances
he'd be in first place but I like Vivek
so we'll talk about that plus ladies and
gentlemen target has lost money in its
sales for the first time in six years
Bud Light is struggling they lost
hundreds of millions of dollars the Bush
family wants to buy back the brand and
sound of Freedom has surpassed Indiana
Jones the reason why they're going after
Trump with pure force is because they're
panicked that they're losing and the
only thing they have left is raw power
which can be terrifying but I think
we're winning and we'll talk a lot more
about that before we get started head
over to castbrew.com hey buy our coffee
in honor of Roberto Jr he's no longer
with us he died suddenly it's
unfortunate it's some kind of heart
defect and um we still do have his
signature rise with Roberto breakfast
blend so definitely pick that up we have
ground we have whole bean you can join
the cast Brew Coffee Club it really is
some of the best coffee I've ever had I
particularly like Appalachian nights and
rise with Roberto Jr we have a few
thousand bags of rise with Roberto Jr
left the coffee is always made fresh to
order but the bags are pre-printed once
we finish this run of bags the new bags
will have in memory of Roberto Jr so if
you want an original first edition bag
pick those up while you still can also
head over to timcast.com click join us
become a member because we're gonna have
a members only uncensored show coming up
for you at 10 pm tonight on tempgas.com
and if you're a member for at least six
months or you sign up at the 25 per
month level you can actually call into
the show and ask us and our guests
questions so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about this and a whole lot of more
is Kingsley Cortez hey guys great to be
with you like Tim said my name is
Kingsley Cortez I am a trump campaign
Alum and I currently do digital media at
the center for newing America I'm also
National Committee woman for the DC
young Republicans great to be with you
all tonight right on thanks for hanging
out we got Phil Labonte hello everybody
I'm Phil Levante lead singer of the
heavy metal band All That Remains
anti-communist and counter-revolutionary
what's going on Ian not too much man
just lifting weights loving life you
know how it is Phil I know how it is hi
everybody Ian Crossland happy to be here
let's rock and roll he actually was
lifting weights earlier he's chasing the
macros I went from 15 pound dumbbells to
25 pound dumbbells today they came in
via UPS and the UPS guy is going and he
puts him down and he's like I don't know
what that is really heavy and then
Sarah's trying to bring it in she's like
what is it I think it was 50 pounds
weights
I was surprised how easy it was you know
you train you get ready for it and then
when you go there it's not as hard as
you think it's going to be that's right
no get it right wing right wing do
prayer hello I am search.com I'm excited
for the episode of gonna see you
Kingsley Let's uh just jump right into
it here's the story my friends and let
the censorship begin in I think it was
2018 they went after Alex Jones they
went after who else did they banned
Laura Loomer milianopolis uh who else
got caught up in that it was a big wave
of people that got uh Sargon he got it
early I think I don't think he was part
of that wave Paul Joseph Watson I think
they went after him they got rid of his
Instagram and it was a bunch of just
pictures of him like smoking a cigarette
with the sun sunset behind him it's like
that was just gotta go he got rid of him
well here's the story Glenn Beck's show
removed from Apple podcast the tech
giant gave the podcaster no warning
prior to his Show's removal scary stuff
he put out this uh video saying what's
the issue and a video shared 2x the
podcaster said the email from Apple's
podcast team contained a link though the
link brought him to another page
informing him his podcast has been
removed from the platform
we found an issue with your show The
Glenn Beck program which must be
resolved before it's available on Apple
podcasts he said I cannot imagine what
they're basing this on the podcaster
said Apple's removal of the Glenn black
program was crazy and encouraged people
to share his post and demand Apple
podcasts to reinstate the show
if this was not Glenn Beck if it was any
other podcast they would not be restored
it's only because it's a high profile
personality in political commentary I
bet Apple nukes tons of shows all the
time and their smaller shows that maybe
you'll get only a few thousand downloads
per episode no one knows it's happening
Glenn Beck said looks like apple
restored my 3 000 plus episodes to their
platform but still don't have clear
answers as to why this happened hope to
have an update for you tomorrow on radio
I want to thank everyone on the left
right and everyone in between who spoke
up today I wish I had better answers
from Apple on what happened but you gave
me hope that the issue of censorship is
still bigger than politics there were a
lot of people on the left who were
saying okay look man like you know you
might not like Glenn Beck but that's
kind of crazy they nuked his show it's
weird that it seems like they've got
like a kill switch for essentially
entire channels I mean well I mean maybe
it makes sense there Rogue employee like
with uh when Donald Trump got banned
from Twitter remember that yeah but
there's even still it's like if there if
there is a rogue employee that's
actually doing the you know shut it off
or whatever it seems like it's something
that's fairly simple for someone to do
as in it doesn't take there's not a lot
of backups there's no doesn't seem like
there's checks in any kind of checks or
anything whatever you know I would think
that it would be like the either one of
the lead developers or like some one of
the one of the owners of the spot was it
Spotify Apple music is that music so
it's like usually most employees don't
have access to shutting off channels
completely unless you're like a really
well-trusted respected administrator but
even then that would be a big risk for
the company to give an administrator
that kind of ability so I'm thinking
like someone up in the in the
development chain Musta which means that
it went through a series of calls like
it wasn't just someone just decided to
do it that someone would have told
someone to do it and then they went
ahead and pushed it and then they
temporarily made it invisible to Glenn
he thought it was deleted but they just
had a invis mode until they could
resolve something I don't know this
happens a lot and um I wonder if this is
a shot across the bow for conservative
commentary and and Glenn Beck being a
conservative commentator but also
obviously anybody who is supporting
Trump in any way pushing back on the
narrative machine I saw this clip Vivek
ramaswamy was talking to Neil Cavuto and
Cavuto was like Donald Trump's now been
indicted you know 90 some odd counts and
Vivek was like clearly it's political
and Cavuto goes you don't think even one
of them I mean certainly and and Vega's
like no Cavuto argues why Trump actually
is guilty because there's so many
charges the fake makes an excellent
point saying we cannot become a country
that simply says because there are so
many charges one of them must be true no
you're innocent until proven guilty but
that shows you where Fox News is at
obviously Fox news is anti-trump
pro-establishment they get rid of Tucker
Carlson we know what's going on now
they're arguing that Trump she must be
guilty in some way
then they go after people like Glenn
Beck they're going to try and take down
Independent Media we've already got
people in the super chat before the show
started saying they can't find this show
well yeah this happens all the time it
should appear on the front page of your
YouTube of YouTube when you go there if
you're subscribed a lot of people are
like I can't find it we've actually had
people say they go to the YouTube
channel for timcast IRL and there's no
live stream it's just not there not
visible for them even though we're live
with you know 30 plus thousand people
watching
if you go to youtube.com live typically
every night we are the number one live
show but people still have a hard time
to find that's one way you can find it
we're gonna get in 2024 and you better
believe it they are going to get rid of
anybody here's what I think if you're
Pro to santis you'll probably be okay
if you are pro-trump you will probably
be hidden I think people if they want to
watch the show can go to timcast.com
every night at 8pm and then you can you
can link to it from the from the
website's front page so start going if
you're having trouble if you ever think
you have trouble you don't want to ever
have trouble go to timcast.com at 8
o'clock Eastern it's right there in the
homepage you can link it through to the
YouTube if you want to watch it from
YouTube or you can just watch it on the
website I think though to the Apple
Point specifically conservatives have
this kind of consensus of thinking that
you know corporations are Untouchable
because we all worship at the altar of
the free market right but what we're
seeing is that these corporations are
taking our freedoms they're acting as
tyrants so I think we we need to get a
lot more comfortable on the right with
you know trust busting certain
corporations are really enforcing
certain laws and just ensuring that they
are protecting the Liberties that the
Constitution and Trust to every single
American it's a bigger issue of the
Republicans they don't do anything yeah
no they write strongly worded letters
that's right that's what our party does
I mean just really good at it yeah no we
are I mean in the wake of the Fulton
County indictment all we're doing is
tweeting we see you know Kevin McCarthy
and various GOP leaders just putting out
statements and fiery tweets there's zero
action and I think the base wants action
the American people see this stuff
they're enraged they're infuriated they
want retribution that's why they love
Donald Trump but I think they're
frustrated with the kind of
establishment Washington D.C cartel
that's just doing nothing what kind of
action could people take like legal you
know righteous action because I'm
racking my brain what could people do in
terms of Corporations I mean there's a
lot that you can do like these
corporations are too massive number one
um they collude with the government
there needs to be a lot more barriers
there that kind of we saw with the
Twitter files right that the government
was actually asking Twitter to do things
and then they were you know complying in
a sense so we need to be sure that that
there are Protections in place so that
that kind of collusion can't happen
so like
so like make them that's yeah what would
that look like though like uh like
putting it making them do it in public I
mean there's always can't force people
to talk in public yeah I mean I think
there needs to be a period of a lot of
transparency and we're seeing a little
bit of that with the weaponization
committee that's happening in Congress
right now we're seeing some of these
files start to come out and we're
getting evidence
um so I think we need more of that I
think we need to kind of uncover what's
been done and then we can kind of go
after these corporations and make sure
you know that they are serving the
interests of the American people when
our Founders conceptualize what a
corporation would be it was kind of akin
to a British Charter it had to serve the
common good it had to be publicly
beneficial to the people that lived in
that country and I think now if you look
at most modern corporations I mean they
act as tyrants They don't serve the
American people at all when did that
happen it was like 1850s when did the
modern Corporation take over it was uh
let's see the first American corporation
was organized in 1894 as Orange County
Title Company company succeeding the two
businesses uh the the business of two
title abstract companies founded in 1889
and operating in Orange County
California is that that's like right
before Rockefeller like got a
Stranglehold on standard oil on the
country with through Standard Oil and
then they eventually broke up Standard
Oil turned it into like six six other
oil companies the Rockefeller still a
piece of so it didn't really so now you
have multinational corporations too like
you have corporations that are working
at the behest of the globally not even
just you know american-centric or
focused they're caring about you know
what Klaus Schwab wants and you can't so
for the American government to go to
like BlackRock and tell it to do
something blackrock's like well where is
their headquarters is it even in the U.S
right now I'm not sure is it in
Switzerland or whatever but they don't
have to because they're not American but
then so we could be like you can't
operate here unless you play by our
rules which as long as we're a strong
robust economy and a force that's that's
has bargaining power but if if people
don't take the US seriously and we tell
Google like hey unless you free your
software code you can't function in the
United States they might just shut down
the United States so it's like and we
could do shows of force like that like
we could tell Apple hey like no or
Amazon you know no more Manufacturing in
China and if they do we seize their boat
when it arrives at a port in California
oh I'd love to see if at any point it
was possible Republicans actually exert
some kind of power they just don't well
yeah that's that that's I honestly I
think that that's asking more than than
is reasonable to expect and what would
you get from Libertarians they would be
even worse with exerting power they'd be
like no it's against our ethos you'd get
a Dave Smith X space at eight o'clock
P.M Eastern right while we're doing our
show today yeah they're doing a live
space you Libertarians ah no I'm just
kidding but like if Libertarians got
elected they'd be like oh oh drat
they're they're doing awful things again
what could they do exactly like well
firstly why do you think that there's
such inactivity on the side of both
political parties and secondly what golf
yeah no they just indicted Trump's
lawyers
are playing Hardball like right okay
well the reason why there's demonic
activities on the side of Democrats is
because they're evil power hungry
Psychopaths and the reason why there's
inaction on the part of the Republicans
is because they're actually Democrats
who are power hungry Psychopaths but
they're only Wham Republican masks so
the uniparty bought out by the
corporations and they're just floating
you know while we're all down on under
the deck trying to put the fire out
there's a handful of Republicans who are
legitimate some of them are more
libertarian leaning some of them are
Maga or anti-establishment but what
there's like 20 of them yeah the other
option is Boycott you know but that's
only what boycott Apple but the boycotts
are working yeah Disney Disney's Shares
are are are at risk because of news
reporting about there's another boycott
happening and they're starting to freak
out Target lost for the first time in
six years massive amounts of money and
their stock dropped by like 27 but light
is on the verge is uh collapsing there's
that's fair enough but Apple there was
one point in the in the in the past
couple years where Apple had more actual
cash than the federal government that's
wild like that's that was a real thing
so whereas yes I I get like boycotts can
can move the needle and stuff uh I'm not
sure apple is who yeah I don't want to
be able to because Apple said that is
more of a global company too they're
they're selling iPhones all over the you
know the whole world so I mean and hey
I'm I'm I'm only telling you my
impression it's I was wrong about the
Bud Light uh boycott in the first place
I didn't think it was a good idea and
apparently I was wrong about that so
fair enough but I think Apple's a bit a
bit of a different company company so
yeah I'm not it's not I'm not too
concerned with apple it'd be only
because Glenn Beck they shut they got
rid of his podcast did that is the one
that came out of my mouth but any kind
of multinational company or American
company that's actually de facto
multinational that's betraying our
interests we could boycott or at least
attempt to you know but then like you
know if these companies get too
integrated in our society and you try
and boycott them like I want to boycott
Microsoft are you kidding me like all my
computers are running Windows right now
I don't know you can get Ubuntu and use
wine I've tried that but I can't game
it's not good yeah for those that are
familiar wine is a way to run Windows
programs on Linux it's just not good
yeah but I love Ubuntu and it is really
is awesome that that people have built
this like open source and a lot of free
software on the platform it's cool it's
cool that it exists only thing I know
about Ubuntu is that's what I used when
I was mining ethereum well I'll tell you
about it is it makes tons of money for
massive multinational corporations
because when they need to operate like
point of sale terminals or
self-checkouts why pay for a license for
Windows on your as your operating system
when Linux is free so a bunch of them
they use Linux a bunch of servers use
Linux because they're like free software
there you go save I shouldn't say makes
the money but saves the money
so we got we got this other news update
I want to pull up this story we got this
tweet from Mike Benz I hope you all are
ready for next year he says this is how
self-sabotaging Linda's new crop of
censorship shills are of their own
company
let me slow down there a minute this
guy's pointing out that Twitter has
begun the process I'm sorry X has begun
the process of hiring election Integrity
team members for 2024 which means
censorship they're hiring sensors
he wasn't mention several of these
individuals have previously expressed
interest for the Twitter killer not
wanting to work for uh here says this
guy who seems to dream of his own
company being killed or reverted to
Twitter 1.0 censorship even positively
promotes that under Linda they're
getting the band back together the band
of policy team means misinfo policies
he's bragging the old sensors are back
okay
do we trust this Linda what is our name
yakarino yeah is that no
yeah yeah that's her name trust her I
don't know no I don't know I mean it
should be assumed that you just right
off the bat like you assume you don't
trust her now I'm not saying that that
it's not possible that she could earn
trust or that it's pot and it's not
possible that that you know
this could be much you do about nothing
but you don't trust off the bat the
truth is you should never have to trust
your social media you should be able to
verify the code and know exactly what
the media is doing secondly they can ban
you at any time for any reason
everywhere you go so there's no reason
in wondering or be getting angry about
it if and when it happens Linda
yaccarino and Elon Musk can ban you off
X right now I don't you bring up like
verifying the code a lot how many I
wonder how many people actually could
verify that like I wouldn't be able to
verify any code like even if they made
the code open source I can't like I
don't know right you might be able to
run it so just chat GPT like an AI
program to like translate the code for
you and let you know what it's saying
well I'm okay that would be your average
person isn't going to be able to verify
that how many how many lines of code do
you think Twitter is I think 18 000 of
them just uh the algorithm so you're
still back to trusting someone to tell
you that oh this is safe yeah so I I
mean you it's it's it the reason I bring
this up is because you say you you
mentioned bring you know verify the code
and have the have open source code and I
still feel like
your your average person is still going
to have to rely on someone else that
they trust because they're not it's like
that's like being like oh we'll make
sure that you know put it put it make it
available so that way people can read it
but then like half the world's
illiterate or whatever it doesn't read
that language you would get like um 10
000 developers that all agreed that the
code says this so it's kind of hard to
have them all lie that that would be
that kind of trust so it's like trust in
the fortification of the mass mentality
I think what would end up happening is
you'd get 80 percent of corporate coders
who align with the Democrats The
Establishment the machine would all come
out and say everything's fine it looks
good to me then you get a small faction
of people being like I don't know this
line of code looks like they're spying
on you and stealing your info then the
corporate price would say far right
neo-nazis claim code is stealing your
info and deranged conspiracy theory I'm
not 100 sure that something just because
of the level of complexity if the
average person can't simply understand
it it might not actually make more
clarity by making the information
available and not saying not saying
they're not saying that that it's a bad
idea that it must be kept secret but I'm
saying that I don't think I don't see
that as a solution because I don't think
that it's go it would make more you know
add more clarity to this average person
it's gonna say I have no idea yeah and
you're gonna get people who will lie
they'll just take a snippet of code and
say this actually does this and then
they could be lying
but when you find out someone was lying
then that destroys their credibility now
look Joe Biden
stated on camera that if you don't fire
the prosecutor knocking the billion
dollars we know for a fact he did it and
they're still saying it's a conspiracy
theory well crazy you're right there was
another story I saw earlier lab leak
theory is still labeled as
misinformation according to these
universities I just hang with developers
and so they they don't lie like they
read code they know exactly what it's
doing and they'll be like yo and then
they make noise about it like mine's the
whole essence of it is free software
code open source code likes those are
like my Bros I I would feel very very
good if the code was available to peruse
yes I agree it should be publicly
available more importantly voting
machine software should be publicly
available information and none of this
would be an issue like there would there
would be no indictment they'd be able to
look at and be like okay well you know I
don't know but they keep it a secret
massive private first of all Dominion is
a multinational corporation is it not I
assume so yeah it's International it's
an international company that handles
our elections I mean that just seems
like a really bad idea yeah like I'm not
saying that Dominion did anything wrong
I'm just saying the United States should
sever all ties with International
organizations that handle our voting and
it should be law listen up Republicans
pass this bill this software code for
voting machines should be public
available have a nice day that's it
there's what's the argument against it
yeah I I mean I I it's kind of any kind
of issue with it with it being available
I mean awesome there are people that I
assume that there might be problems in
the fact that it's proprietary like if
you have uh intellectual property issues
with that right too bad go home you
should not be able to operate an
election oh for like fair enough okay
yeah yeah yeah okay I mean you can make
software code that people don't get
access to but you're the election
machine all software on it the code must
be publicly available for people to
review and see sure yeah if there's
little lines in there that let people
flip tallies and stuff uh I'm gonna
point you to what's that guy's name that
a software developer that testified in
Congress that he wrote a program the
flip votes 5149 this is like from the
year 2000 I'll pull it up in a minute
I mean I think like two we're gonna see
a lot of issues in 24 just in terms of
voter trust like there are so many
members of the base out there especially
Trump space that just don't believe that
their 2024 ballot is going to be counted
correctly and that is a massive problem
and Republicans like you said don't do
anything they don't seem to have any
plan to address that we haven't changed
any of these voter laws that the
Democrats switched in the dead of night
in 2020. they're still on the book
seriously there's been not like I don't
know
I don't know who to look to to get this
stuff done I I figure Ron Ronald
McDaniel I guess if there has been no mo
no movement no effort taken by the
Republicans to make sure that they're in
a different position uh strategically
for this election then I mean then all
of the talking about Donald Trump or or
talking about DeSantis or Vivek or
whoever all that stuff is just horse
crap it doesn't matter if the
Republicans have not taken measures to
prevent the type of electioneering that
happened last night that dude let's pass
a bill I think Tom this is Thomas
Massey's ball game and I would love to
get Kevin McCarthy involved I don't know
I haven't talked to Matt Gates I'm sure
would love to hear this any bill that
gets passed has to get through the
Senate and through the president and
anything that might help the Republicans
is not going to happen so you have to
think of things if the if the Congress
right now has power to do things like
like affect like uh um the purse string
so like they'll they cannot fund stuff
so if there's something that they want
to affect they can be like well we're
not going to pass pass a bill that pays
for it but if Congress just passes a
bill that you know is a or a bill that
in the hopes of becoming a law the
Senate's not going to pass it and and
and Biden's not going to sign it so
passing a bill would be a way even even
talking about passing themselves yes
state level of their own elections so
the problem is is are people in various
even red States aren't mobilized this
has I think been a problem on our side
for a long time the left being an
activist being political is almost their
hobby are people you know we do our nine
to five we kind of check out we're not
involved in what's going on in our
community at all so I think that's a
disadvantage I think also we don't have
enough lawyers on our side it seems that
they have just endless lawyers that are
willing to litigate and fight this stuff
so I always tell people like get off the
sidelines you have to run for school
board you have to like be an election
poll Watcher do whatever you can because
too many of us are just totally checked
out and we're asleep at the wheel you
think it's cool for people to run for
school board if they don't have kids
yeah why not I mean if you're involved
in your community absolutely
so you think you think that either will
be less likely to on the right to go and
vote because they feel that their
election would their vote is not going
to be counted is that we were saying
I've talked to a lot of people that feel
that way really I certain people have
said the opposite because you're like
I'm gonna go out and go vote first thing
the first day and paper or whatever but
I hope so yeah I don't know I just want
to yeah I just I hear kind of like
discouragement I think is the
overwhelming sense like I don't know I I
hope my vote counts this I hear I hear
the opposite there's there's a meme
where it's from the wildfires in New
York and then the cameras panning past
like the Williamsburg Bridge and
everything's orange then it shows Trump
dancing and then it's and then Scrolls
past him and says don't care still
voting Trump yeah what I'm hearing all
the memes are people just saying
whenever they're like Trump did this
Trump did that the election's rigged
whatever people just say don't care
still voting Trump yeah yeah I'm sure
that's what I'm saying yeah that's the
meme I mean if that Meme holds Trump
wins yeah if people are just like don't
know don't camera to vote for him anyway
I think two they'll be pushed to act and
to vote the more he becomes indicted or
just like has the deal Jay totally
weaponized against him this is gearing
people up for Retribution they're ready
for it I just think I just think it
doesn't matter at all we saw how bad it
was in 2016. it's been ramping up 2016.
the Democrats
screamed until blood sprayed from their
eyes that Donald Trump was a Soviet spy
who stole the election all of the
craziest conspiracy nonsense 2020 Trump
and his supporters believed and screamed
the High Heavens there was voter fraud
to the point where you had many people
saying Trump was secretly still the
president it's insane 2024 is going to
be no different no different whatsoever
I've got the name worse it'll be it'll
be it'll be different in the sense that
it will be escalating this developer's
name is Clinton Eugene Curtis and he
testified uh that he that Congressman
Tom Feeney asked him to build a
prototype software package that would
secretly rig an election to sway the
result 5149 to a specified side he
testified that in front of U.S House
Judiciary members in Ohio and the
YouTube video is called American
election hacker testifies it's by an
account called hack247 if you want to
watch the video he is almost giddy
letting people know let's get political
my friends
we got the story from the post
millennial Trump Giuliani and others to
be booked at Fulton County Jail suspects
in Fulton County are booked and
arraigned on two separate occasions so
according to standard procedure Donald
Trump will be in County lockup a not so
special prison the left calls it
decrepit and say people die there
so I have a few questions how do first
how do they handle something like this
but more importantly
what would happen
and everyone's saying it won't happen so
fine sure whatever I'm not saying it
will happen I'm saying question what
would happen if with these charges
Donald Trump his associates or any one
of these individuals refuses to go to
Georgia and surrender what happens then
fugitive charges
so there's interesting constitutional
provision and it's it's it's really just
absolutely hilarious the armchair people
on Twitter who have no idea what's going
on in this world and think they know
everything and that's not everybody I'm
just saying they exist
one person brought up a really good
point saying the Constitution says if
someone flees from Justice then the feds
can intervene to bring the person back
to that state but what if you're not in
the state and weren't in that state in
the state accuse you of a crime the
legal argument is that you are fleeing
from Justice by not surrendering but
this would mean if Donald Trump Sydney
Powell Jenna Ellis or any one of these
individuals refuses to surrender their
state would have to cooperate law
enforcement would have to be sent out by
Joe Biden to take in a former
presidential Administration official or
lawyer and bring them to Georgia to be
brought to jail
what happens
it's interesting Rhonda Santa said that
he would not assist in any extradition
of Donald Trump
Donald Trump of course is currently in
Bedminster but what if he goes down to
Mar-A-Lago it would be awesome Tim it
would be just the most awesome thing
ever to see that it would I mean and it
would be terrible for the country I'm
aware and there are people that are mad
I don't know if that's true either
he goes like push the envelope make them
come get you I want those options I
think I think they should have to go
serve documentation to Trump I think
Donald Trump
not gonna get a a fair Shake in uh
Bedminster he's up in New Jersey good
luck with that I think Trump his perfect
play is to go to Florida
make DeSantis
put it put his money where his mouth is
and this is not a dig under Santas it's
like do you have the the Integrity
upholds what you've said but more
importantly if Georgia has an issue they
don't deliver this via press conference
on TV if they're going to a restaurant
they have to go to his residence and
serve him the arrest documents this is a
it's such a strange phenomenon that
people are like Donald Trump should go
surrender yeah if they serve him legal
paperwork
and say hello Donald Trump here's the
legal paperwork you can take a copy of
it bring it to your lawyers you have to
you can surrender in 10 days or you will
be arrested all right what's happening
now is this lady goes on TV and says we
expect them to surrender in 10 days
that's not legal you can't go on TV and
be like I'm suing them it's like okay
well until I actually have legal
documents saying I'm being sued with a
court signature and all that stuff
you're not doing anything for all Trump
knows there was never even a grand jury
how's he supposed to know that how is he
supposed to probably knows the
prosecutor on TV and is just like come
on down Trump and she can take a picture
with him and smile get autograph
unless I'm not literally suggesting
that's what she's doing but for Trump
and all these defendants
their lawyers are going to have to be
served some kind of paperwork or
documentation and I think the smartest
play for Trump is to go to Mar-A-Lago
and just say
if you are charging me you can deliver
the documents to my residence where I
will answer for them and then we will
discuss terms of either surrender or a
legal challenge yeah and I mean Trump
was acting in his Federal capacity
during this entire thing as like a
Federal Officer so I'm not even
convinced that a state has the authority
necessarily to arrest him for something
like that I guess we'll see it might go
all the way to the Supreme Court but
what they're doing to these folks is
just despicable I mean my colleague Jeff
Clark is one of the one ones who's been
indicted
um along with President Trump acting
Assistant Attorney General yeah I mean
wow
wow no it's absolutely Bonkers and he
was just providing legal advice right he
was just telling Trump this is how I
think that you could apply the law and
for that crime which is not even a crime
right they're saying it is it's totally
Preposterous well Jenna Ellis I think is
the funniest because she's being charged
with just being Trump's lawyer right
that's that's basically it
by just being his lawyer they're getting
they're charging her with uh Rico yeah I
mean that's I I firmly believe it's
about intimidation it's like I said last
night it's it's about the establishment
wanting to intimidate the population
including lawyers you know anyone and
anyone that might run in the future
like these are talented people that are
going to be put on the sidelines while
they have to deal with all of this
that's the point but I want to I want to
speculate here what do you think happens
if they don't surrender
is it something really boring like a guy
shows up knocks on the door and says I
have a warrant for your roast and they
go okay and then they get in the car and
they drive off I don't know who the
Secret Service actually answers to
because if the Secret Service answers to
Donald Trump the Secret Service are
armed and they'll be they'll have plenty
of of gear to actually pose a serious
threat so if anyone is gonna go pick up
Donald Trump and the Secret Service
actually answers to him as opposed to
answering to DC and they listen to him
and he says don't let them come take me
we could have a SWAT team with a gun
fight with or an FBI hostage rescue team
in a fight with secret service and
gunfight with secret service over Donald
Trump if that's if that's how world war
three or whatever starts I never saw
that coming civil war well that's what
how Civil War you never know I mean I I
and this is all just you know a dude
that yells at a stick for a living
talking out of his ass so take it for
not like it which is nothing it's worth
nothing but I mean you know like I I
don't know how the the the Secret
Service how the the yeah with the
command structure is exactly so I don't
know what happens but it if it is it's
possible but like because the Secret
Service is supposed to protect Donald
Trump and even if Donald Trump does get
picked up and and goes to jail none of
that takes away the fact that he's got
Secret Service protection for the rest
of his life so that means that there's
going to be secret service he's gonna
have to be in a special jail
some type of special jail and secret
service is going to have to rotate in
and out of his cell because they're not
going to leave him alone with a cellmate
you can't like he's got Secret Service
protection for the rest of his life you
know but the Secret Service his own
secret service if he were to start
committing murder like starting to
murder people on the street his own
secret service would have to stop him I
would imagine They don't serve him they
serve the law in the in the post
president
I don't know that the Secret Service is
obligate I would assume the guy the
human being that is the Secret Service
Officer like or whatever if if Donald
Trump decided to start just mowing
people down I assume he would stop him
that being said I don't think the Secret
Service is any more obligated to stop
someone that's committing a criminal act
then the regular police are and the
regular police are not obligated the
Supreme Court has decided that they're
not so I don't know that they that they
would be obligated to stop him but I
would assume that a normal human being
in in the role of secret service officer
would probably stop the Fair former
president but I'm killing people there
are people right now saying on Twitter
that to end this right now Donald Trump
need refused to surrender publicly State
he will challenge us to the Supreme
Court that one the actions they're
challenging him on are protected as he
was president at the time and that the
leaking of the indictment before the
grand jury voted proves that this is a
political conspiracy to steal or seize
power there's a legal argument not the
way I described it there's a legal way
to describe it improper unconstitutional
actions or something like that
some people have said Trump can Trump
and Republicans can end this right now
by doing what needs to be done I don't
know if that if I agree with that I
don't know what would happen I have no
idea for all it's entirely possible that
what the Democrats are trying to do is
muster up some kind of reaction so that
they can use it to justify more if Trump
doesn't surrender they then go and say
he's a fugitive from Justice and that
instantly justifies the removal from his
name of his name from The Ballot or
something like that
maybe Trump says okay we go to court
then he files a bunch of extensions he
files to have a transfer to Fulton uh
out of Fulton County to uh federal court
like what Mark Meadows is doing and that
delays the process until the election
takes place and his name says in the
ballot that might be the correct
strategy for this it does seem like they
will all be surrendering Giuliani for
instance said that he's planning
sometime next week to go down my
question is what would happen if they
don't and then you know if Trump stays
in Florida for instance for one that
puts tremendous pressure on Ronda
Sanchez I don't know if Trump wants to
do that because Santa's already falling
in the polls
however it does create pressure it would
force DeSantis to defend Trump which can
either put descendants in a difficult
position where now he's 100 on board
with Maga and Against the Machine the
opportunity there is is DeSantis really
anti-deep state or whatever well here's
your opportunity if Trump then refuses
and says serve me the paperwork and my
lawyers will negotiate then he has time
without going to jail no mug shot no no
jail time and then he gets the Supreme
Court to issue a ruling on it and crush
it instantly before they can pull off
whatever weird scheme they want to pull
off
I don't know I have no idea what happens
here's what I prefer I guess
if uh I suppose the simple surface level
uh response I could give is I think
Trump would be better off not
surrendering and simply saying
I have not received any legal
documentation notification in my home
state of any charges against me from
anyone else
the simple Act of a press conference is
not a legal declaration that gives them
the authority to take any actions when
my local law enforcement make contact
with my attorneys as per any pending
charges or extradition another state I
will absolutely respond with legal
documents that's what he should do and
he should do it from Florida not from
New Jersey although the tennis
supporters want Rhonda Santos to throw
him under the bus so
I don't know what you get with that I
think too we have to remember like
questioning an election's legitimacy is
something that has happened throughout
this country for you know centuries
almost I mean Jackson questioned his 24
election and would reportedly walk
around talking about how it was stolen
you had Bush you had Stacey Abrams
countless individuals do this sort of
thing when there's evidence of
widespread fraud or they think there is
evidence of widespread fraud in Trump's
case there actually was massive fraud
whether that was you know the censorship
of the hunter Biden story and how media
kind of co-opted Voters access to
various sources of information on the
Biden family or whether that was you
know a pipe bursting in an Atlanta
ballot count Center I like cheating
better than fraud yeah because fraud
some people you say that people might
think cheating but some people might
think legal fraudulent actions like fake
battles and stuff cheating is better the
shadow campaign to steal the election
that Time Magazine published that's
cheating withholding the hunter Biden
laptop cheating changing the rules at
the executive level without approval
from the state legislature cheating what
they're doing right now by arresting
Donald Trump his lawyers and the former
presidential administration's personnel
cheating I like cheating better I like
the word manipulating but I think we're
all right I mean I think I don't know if
it's technical fraud either but I think
it's both look cheating manipulative and
cheating I mean you could say it's
cheating get a man on the street go to
Times Square the thing is it didn't
break the rules yes it did just change
the rules it did break the rules oh then
it is true yeah so the Constitution says
that the state legislature has final
Authority on how the elections are run
and how electors are assigned and when
you got Governors changing the rules
without the approval of the state
legislature and courts bypassing the
state legislature that was in violation
of the Constitution thus taxes filed a
lawsuit under original jurisdiction to
the Supreme Court saying the way that
these states handled their elections
violates the Constitution and thus it it
uh it's uh what do they say basically
it's stripping Texas of their right to a
free and fair election if other states
are violating the Constitution the
Supreme Court just said screw you we
don't want to hear it
so instead of actually hearing the
arguments on the merits the Supreme
Court just said leave us out of it why
because they're evil and corrupt people
and cower Thomas and Alito I think were
the ones who were like we must hear this
argument yeah they were afraid to
because they were afraid to hear the
argument and then find in favor of
Donald Trump because it had there was
Merit to it and it was like it wasn't
even in favor of trump it was Texas
saying if we do our elections by the
Constitution and Pennsylvania and
Wisconsin and Georgia and Michigan or
whatever don't then there was no
legitimate election yeah it's like
basically saying you and 10 of your like
you and 10 of your buddies are going to
decide who how much money you pitch in
by lunch and then one of your friends
just gives a bunch of counterfeit bills
and you're like no no no why am I
spending twenty dollars we all agree
everyone puts in 20 bucks his 20 bucks
wasn't real or at least I don't know if
it was real and they say nah shut up you
don't you don't get to there were
articles written or about like the
discussions they had about whether or
not they would take make this and they
were concerned about the reaction the
population would have if they found in a
way that would help Donald Trump they
were really really concerned about it
that the Supreme Court Justice Jenna
Ellis yeah I don't have it is being
criminally indicted under Rico charges
for the simple Act of being Trump's
lawyer
Mark Meadows was Trump's chief of staff
former presidential Administration chief
of staff was indicted for that reason
these people in the Supreme Court were
probably pissing in their pants sitting
in the corner crying begging for
forgiveness saying I'll do whatever you
say
Clarence Thomas was like nah and I think
I think it was Alito and Thomas were
like screw that we don't care yeah the
way I see it we cannot rely on the
courts Congress has kind of rendered
itself useless the executive I think is
truly the only way we can save this
country is by using that authority to
you know defund different agencies and
do things like that and just totally go
after this woken weaponized deep State
this bureaucracy so I think you know
this is really the most important
election because it's kind of our last
chance but if it's if it's about funding
then the Republicans are in a position
now where they should be able to do it
because they had they they have but they
don't have the Senate like you have the
Office of Management and budget if
you're president you can totally cut
agents budget or agencies oh I mean look
fair enough the Republicans are going to
vote on this Government funding bill and
they're absolutely going to fund all of
these intelligence agencies and law
enforcement agencies that are being
weaponized against Trump and Trump
supporters the Republicans have the
power right now to simply be like we
will not vote on any funding for the
government that includes funding for the
FBI
they're all bought and paid for are they
corrupt is corrupt can be their evil
people are they as fatigue as I am about
it guess what happens though man they
want you to be yeah they want to wear
you down and then just make you be like
I don't care anymore just do whatever
don't you want to just play Magic the
Gathering yeah hey Baldur's Gate just
came out build some muscle eat healthy
make some funny movies laugh cry all
right look at my kids eyes that's all I
want to do never mind that we're putting
mercury in your drinking water never
mind that we're putting Florida in your
drinking water never mind that that
chemical spill over there just killed a
whole bunch of people and the island
just burned down don't forget forget all
about that don't worry about what we're
doing why don't you just go drink some
more Milkshakes that are full of
microplastics or eat some cardboard with
some milk poured all over it and some
sugar crystals
that's what they want you to do I want
to do it but here's the question my
friends here's the question we've all
seen The Matrix
would you rather sit there in that fancy
restaurant with Cipher cutting that fine
filet mignon saying I don't care if it's
real or would you rather be in the
Nebuchadnezzar eating slime
oh yeah that sounds like good though I
would try I'd rather be Neo
that was bad oh sure it's like Ben
metal
he wants to be the one yeah that's
that's the point everybody wants to be
this yeah this is the point you can
choose to plug back in
shut it all down and say do whatever you
want with absolute power oppress maim
hurt whatever I don't care I just want
to drink my Bud Light and eat chicken
wings
or we can eat the Slime and or that's
right you can do what's right does that
mean or civil rights and freedom and
honor and integrity and the Constitution
and the preservation of the future and
you got to eat slime while you do it
I'll do slime over bugs what's the slime
in this metaphor is it just that you got
to keep talking about it they were
eating Amino I mean but for us like the
suffering involved with with pushing
ahead with this is just keep talking
about it don't let up you know because I
don't want to talk about Donald Trump
every day I got other stuff to do I want
to do other things with my life but I
will keep talking about it that's what
we need to do to say world war three is
on the horizon it always is what sort of
there's there's escalating degrees of
conflict since the Cold War yeah Korea
Korea the Korean war was the closest the
Doomsday Clock has ever been to zero
now we have active warfare in Eastern
Europe for the first time and I think
what five five or six decades you've got
Russia saying that they're at war with
us and this wasn't happening when Donald
Trump was president
so
there's a lot of uh a lot of people who
view this as Joe Biden is beholden to
Ukraine because of favors he did and he
is terrified of what happens if this
information gets out so he's dumping
money into Ukraine so that they can win
their territorial dispute with their
neighbor Russia for which we have very
little involvement but for some reason
are giving them hundreds of billions of
dollars which could lead to World War
III you vote for Donald Trump
and then maybe we get some border
security that's imperfect you get a guy
who's mean in the white house but the
economy does a little bit better jobs
start coming back to the U.S the war
machine starts breaking down you know it
seems like it's the better path to take
do you think that this is like I'm not I
don't like bringing up God God's way of
saying it's just so generic but like is
this God's way of saying Vivek ramaswami
should be the president
you know path of least resistance
personally I don't know that God talks
like that if if Trump is indicted I'm
sorry Trump isn't dead if Trump is
convicted and imprisoned and stripped
from the ballot and then just one day is
gone and no one knows where he went
they will then come out and say Vivek
ramaswamy once you know sacrificed a
goat and punched a kid in the face
they'll just you'll get all the craziest
stories they'll make up whatever they
have to make up they'll pull quotes out
of context they'll argue that people
have no right to change opinions they'll
say his opinion from two years ago when
the narrative was different is is his
principal opinion now and already some
people are trying to do that he's
climbing in the polls so what do we hear
we are like did you know that two years
ago Vivek ramaswamy was in favor of this
covet policy and I'm like so was Trump
like and then people change their
opinions when they saw the data people
change their opinions all the time one
hour and RFK as well people are like
yeah but RFK said this thing about gun
control back then and I'm like and
what's he saying now so you could you
can believe that they're lying that's
fair okay but everybody said one thing
yesterday and something else today I
mean because people learn stuff and they
change but anyway my point is DeSantis
let's say Trump gets indicted convicted
or again he wasn't died I'll say he gets
convicted and he's removed from the
ballot Rhonda sandis jumps to the number
one position he narrowly defeats Vivek
ramaswamy they're gonna come out and say
he's a predator they're gonna come out
and say he raped somebody they're gonna
look what they did to Brett Kavanaugh
some Rand this guy was already vetted
Brett Kavanaugh was already vetted as a
federal judge he had gone to the Press
already then all of a sudden out of the
blue they accused him of being a gang
rapist yeah and Tara Reid was accusing
Joe Biden of sexually they claimed her
party but she didn't get a lot of media
attention like uh I wonder why yeah I
wonder they said Brett Kavanaugh was
party to events where men would line up
outside of bedrooms where women were
held captive and gang raped and Men took
turns that's what they claimed about
Brett Kavanaugh this census ain't gonna
be immune to that the only thing
stopping it right now is that he's in
he's typically in second place in some
polls in third
anybody who jumps to first place is
getting that exact same treatment I
think Casey the fact that Casey has
cancer might help Stave off those kind
of attacks a little bit I don't think
that's Ron's one I think so no we're up
against the most demonic depraved people
we've ever seen they'll say Ron Pizza
beats his wife they'll say that if Ron
jumps into first place for whatever
reason a story will come out where
someone says that when when his wife had
cancer they saw Ron strike her in the
face with it with a with an open Palm or
whatever it'll it'll be it'll be
nonsense it'll be a former babysitter
and she's like he once came home drunk
and screamed in her face while she was
she was sick and then he and then he
smacked her and then he's gonna but it's
not true and case is gonna bet this is
insane it's never happened and they're
gonna say you have battered wife
syndrome they're a really good Rhonda
Santos deep fix it really sounds like
him and did you see the Steve Carell one
obviously from the office hilarious
there's another one a couple days ago I
just saw him it's not coming to mind
what it was what it was but it was like
uh please clap one of those
yes Ron doing something something but
they got his voice on lock it really
sounds like Ron DeSantis so if they want
to make it sound like he's doing
something over a phone call or something
I mean the technology is available let's
uh let's let's jump into the story
it's over for Ron Trump cheers new poll
showing Vivek ramaswamy overtaking
DeSantis for the number two spot in the
2024 GOP Primary still miles behind him
but many people are suggesting that the
Trump campaign is propping up these
polls propping up the vague ramaswamy
because the fake is no real threat to
Trump and actually is nice to Trump
supports Trump in many ways and may
actually be you know just effectively on
Trump's sideways to send us his real
competition for him
this is I think this might be the second
or third poll showing that Vivek has
taken second place so if Trump's out of
the picture of Vivek may come in first I
don't know for sure in the prediction
markets we have Ron still in second
place but it looks like uh Vivek and Ron
are tied and the only reason Rhonda
sandis is above him is because D comes
before R alphabetically as a people have
argued I don't know if that's true I
think we can jump down here and just see
that uh so right now they're saying that
it's actually 17 to 16. so DeSantis is
in second place but I'm curious what you
guys think about uh about this battle
and where Vivek ramaswami ends up
because I think
I've I watched this really great clip I
mentioned earlier between him and Neil
Cavuto man this dude is as sharp as
sharp can be he's sharpest sharp as a
box of knives this Vivek ramaswamy he
knows what to say how to say it and uh I
don't think a guy like Vivek is purely
genuine it would be absurd to believe
that this guy is a saint who just
believes the right things and and has
Whispers all the sweet nothings into
your ears he's a snake I said it before
I love snakes snakes are dangerous you
can hide in the grass and if you don't
see him there you're gonna pay he's the
kind of guy that will go in there and
change things for the better
unexpectedly I I trust him I I don't
know him that well but I I don't I'm
agreeing with what you're saying I don't
think he's saying everything all true
like George Washington he was a master
liar yeah that's my metaphors that's
like that's that's the Other Extreme
yeah he's the dude no step on snake bro
like do not mess with this this is what
I'm talking about he's that kind of guy
I think Vivek has over overwhelmingly
positive position that he's correct on
and there's a few things that he saw he
was pulling bad on and probably switched
to switch the narrative yeah that's
normal politics for anybody I think
overwhelmingly based on my conversations
with him he's legit genuine he really
does dislike the ESG stuff he's really
threat he really thinks it's a threat to
this country and he wants to win to push
back on it but here's what ends up
happening you're someone like Vivek
what's your specialty he did biotech he
did uh anti-esg financing those are his
areas of expertise when it comes to
issues of like government lockdowns in
war and foreign policy not as areas of
expertise so he gets into this and then
he's like I gotta figure out what's the
appropriate path to take when it comes
to foreign policy that's not my thing
and then he comes out with an opinion
that is
Incorrect and he gets heavily criticized
for it then six seven months later we
hear him again and he comes out with the
correct opinion that doesn't mean he's a
snake it means that he was like I don't
know enough about it I end up learning
about it and here's where I actually
stands I think when I say snake in the
sense that he's gonna go in there and
twist the pharmaceutical industry on its
head and no one has any idea it's coming
yeah like he he's not gonna even
intimate his intention
I think snake is kind of implying he's
uh evil oh I disagree I love snakes I
used to play with snakes when I was
little snake pooped on me once a garter
oh wow that's great kind of like a bird
poop this is just right out the skin you
know there's a difference between snake
poop and burp poop right bird poop is
lucky because they're flying around
snake poop is just kind of on you yeah
it was just on me I'm a big fan of
snakes snakes have no hate man they
really only will attack it well if
they're frightened or attacked you know
they don't really if Trump trump is the
lion and they call you know the Maga
party the Maga symbol is the lion what's
Ron and what's Vivek Ron's the Rhino
[Laughter]
Vivek the snake Rama
oh that's mean no those are both it's a
dangerously powerful creature of the
snake run the Rhino and the fake the
snake yeah geez Trump supporter Maga
2024 Ian over here no well I think I've
called Vivek I said that I like a noodle
snake probably like three months ago
because what I see in him is that he's
not playing his hand you don't know what
he's got and he's a not a billionaire
have a brilliant strategist the guy is a
is a hundred was hundreds of millions of
dollars
Donald Trump is going to come out in the
primaries and be like rhino run and
Vivek the snake
Donald Trump it's Donald Trump all the
way that's if you they want to hit
Donald it's Donald Trump I if could you
imagine if Trump starts using Ian's
the snake Robert you know Jake the Snake
Roberts
Rhino Ron is better than Randy it is
wow use the my powers for good and uh
Rama swampy I forgot who said that was
that Alex bruceowitz who said that I
don't think so no I remember the Trump
people tend to like here's here's what I
think the Trump supporters like
ramaswamy for one simple reason he
defends Trump on principle and correctly
well he defends principal yeah he
defends principle and Donald Trump's
part of that principle it's not like it
could be anybody plug anybody into it
he'd still defend the process but when
and so I know all the distance people
are going to be like de Santa said that
these things were wrong too
When Donald Trump was being indicted
over what he got died over the Stormy
Daniels thing right is that that was the
first one the first one Ron said look I
don't know what goes into paying a porn
star hundreds of thousand dollars people
were like low blow like it it didn't
it's not the same like the Vex
approaches what they're doing to Trump
is wrong it is unjust and we must oppose
it Ron's position was more tepid even
the Fulton County indictment he just you
know gave a blanket I'll end the
weaponization of government statement he
always says I haven't read the
indictment which is odd to me um and
never mentions Trump by name so yeah I
think Trump supporters appreciate Rama
Swami going to the mat for him and and
being true to principals and I think if
DeSantis did that he would have a lot
more Goodwill with Trump supporters yeah
this is the funny thing I love that
Santa supporters are the most
entertaining people I tweeted uh what
happens if Donald Trump doesn't
surrender what happened you know will
the feds be sent to whatever state he's
in what if he flees to a red State and
they refuse to cooperate I get a
combination of Georgia the red states
that I'm like yes it's the one state he
has to go to to surrender so obviously
I'm not talking about him seeking refuge
in Georgia where he'll clearly be
arrested by Georgia police and then I I
followed up with Ronda Santa said that
that Trump should have fired these
Source prosecutors and Christopher Ray
and all that and previously stated that
he would not assist an act tradition so
I tweeted will Rhonda if he went to
Florida would Ronda Sanders stand by his
word and refuse to extradite Trump and
all of a sudden all of his head
supporters not every single one but a
bunch of them start insulting and
attacking me
claiming that my post was insulting to
Ron DeSantis and I'm just like yo this
is why the guy's losing
his base for whatever reason Ron
DeSantis has cultivated people who
assume any discussion of Rhonda Sanders
is an insult yeah they attack anybody
who brings up anything about him I can
only assume that the Trump campaign
hired shills to go on Twitter and attack
anyone while pretending while pretending
to be to Santa supporters so that nobody
wants to support the Santos dude so I
noticed a lot of the tdsers are the ones
who support centers oh like a lot and
the tdsers like this there are people
that are extremely extremely mad about
Trump you know so I feel like it's kind
of like it became a thing because so
many of them were on his side you know
they just kind of have this visceral
reaction against Trump that's what
they're wrote into census they were
there were a lot of uh Republicans and
conservatives in 2016 who despised Trump
and did everything in the power to stop
him right then after a year or two they
were totally on board with Trump why
because of social pressure Trump won
yeah if they were not with Trump then
they were this weird they were Democrats
and so what ends up happening is these
neocons
they split into two factions we now
agree Trump is good please don't yell at
me and Trump was always bad we're gonna
go hang out with Democrats then you get
the Lincoln project I love the Lincoln
project so much because they were like
now that Trump has been defeated in 2020
they're like we're gonna start going
after other Republicans and it's just
like why
like Trump was the bad guy right why go
after literally any other Republican
don't you like Mitch McConnell he's your
guy huh no because it was grifting they
just wanted to find a group of people
that griffed off of and make money for
or make money from sorry yeah what I
love about Trump is like he's the great
revealer in many ways he's shown us who
these people truly are to their core
whether that's you know deep State
bureaucrats or your average never Trump
never Trumper on Twitter he has shown us
what these people are thinking so they
can no longer lie to us he's kind of
pulled the curtain back and I think
that's been an immense service to The
Republic yeah and that's why he has so
many a huge part of why I have so many
fans because he just he talks straight
and like you were talking about we're in
the apocalypse we're in this great
revealment time era where and he's just
like talking about the Deep State openly
and like for people that had been red
pilled they already kind of knew but to
hear it from the president while he's
president is like man people needed that
right even the DC consultant class like
before Trump I had no idea how much
disdain peat like Coastal Elites or DC
Beltway consultant have for average
Americans that just live regular
day-to-day lives I didn't know how much
they despise my values until Donald
Trump
can I also just point out with all due
respect to Kyle Kolinski he did not know
what a farm looked like well yeah he he
was he took he took a picture from a
plane calculusky is a very prominent uh
left-wing podcaster personality he's a
good dude he tries really hard and I
have tremendous respect for him because
he tries to be honest he just has
different opinions that's great him and
crystal ball they're fantastic
but the point is even among the people
that we can say we like and are good
people he posted a photo from a plane of
farms and said I wonder why it looks
that way and it's just like he got
roasted for it and insulted and it was
mean and I'm like yo this is an
educational opportunity for a coastal
Elite like Kyle to understand the world
that rural folk live in by simply saying
my friend good sir those are farms but
was was he asking why because food comes
he did not understand what he was
looking wasn't he asking why do the
Farms look that way no no no no no no no
no he said what are those things that
was the substance of his question he
said I don't know why the land looks
like yeah that's right that's right I
think we have the Tweet right here
actually it's this he said
let's just do this and find an actual
image
here we go he said this land by the uh
this is land by Colorado Kansas border
from a plane pretty cool I have no idea
how slash why it looks like this dude
it's called farming it's called property
line how do you not know that man and
that's that's that I'm sorry it is
absolutely wild I don't know how you
don't know yeah for something to be
popular and to be ignorant is like
pretty disturbing but it happens it's
it's so beyond that it's it's it's like
you don't know how did you not know what
Farms I just my mind is blown by this
yeah me too well you can look at like a
you know a neighborhood and see
properties like those are yards it looks
like you did like Old MacDonald Had a
Farm like you know like it's so weird
what the heck Sean Davis said imagine
being mystified by the existence of
farms I am not bringing this up to like
we we've brought it up periodically it's
from a long time ago what what years I
don't know if we know what year it's
from years a couple years ago a couple
years ago and again like I like Kyle
he's a good dude he's he's a smart guy
but my point is not that he's a bad
person it's that no even when we're
taught you you talk about the the
Beltway people who despise rural Folk
think about people like Kyle who do who
does a show where he's very uh favorable
to Democrats in the left and he
literally doesn't know what a farm even
looks like these are the kind of people
and again not trying to drag Kyle but
these are the people that when I've been
on Twitter and was talking about
inflation I and and uh disruption of
supply line when I said what happens
when this Farm can't produce milk where
you get your milk from they responded
with the store
I am not exaggerating and I said I get
that my point is where does the store
get their milk from and they responded
with what are you talking about it's
just there I am not exaggerating that is
a Verbatim quote from people on from a
guy on Twitter I got into an argument
with socialists with sickle and hammers
in their accounts and they say things
like it's just at the store dude what do
you mean oh they're trolling no no dude
they still got you talking about no you
know you see you see the issue
I spent a decade Plus on the ground at
various protests where I've physically
spoken with these people and have
experienced this over and over again and
you call it a troll yet Kyle kalinsky
did not know what a farm looked like
yeah but a random internet commenter
although that's why I would say it's a
troll I would just assume it's a troll
first a high profile socialist account
with like 40 000 followers who post
about this all the time that says
something like that is no different from
Kyle Kolinski saying he doesn't know the
farm okay 40 000 followers that's a
different story I'm not talking like a
guy with 10 followers okay there's like
a pro they're like prominent you know I
got to an argument with the Socialist
Party of Great Britain that one was
hilarious when I was just like
it was a similar conversation what
happens if somebody wants to build a car
as a hobby they're like they can go and
just get free car parts from the factory
and I'm like like every communist system
for free you can just literally for no
reason go somewhere just take whatever
you want if the people knew you not
technically untrue because they use
brute force to do it like if someone
knew you and they wanted to agitate you
they could message you on Twitter and be
like just say really in names and stuff
until you can't take it anymore and then
on TV and yell about it I don't think
Kyle's goal with not knowing what a farm
was was intending to trick right Wingers
into thinking he was a I think he
genuinely didn't know from that it's
like that Meme ha jokes on them I'm just
pretending to be
like no dude there are a lot of people
that don't understand what supply chain
is and so in the supply line there are
people that don't understand where milk
comes from but dude coming from the
store like it just operates at the store
is the most bizarre concept it's not
it's bro it's called there's a concept
of object permanence but there's people
who let's try the this you ever see that
visualization test where it says
I chose a picture it shows five
silhouettes of a person and there's a
picture of an apple a drawing of an
apple a flat single monotone drawing of
an apple an outline of an apple and then
nothing and it says which do you see in
your mind when you think of Apple
there are some people who say what do
you mean do you see you can see things
in your mind some people can't visualize
objects in their minds some people can
in their mind visualize a
three-dimensional Apple spin it around
slice it in half open it up and that's
the visualization abilities they use for
conceptualizing Bridges and buildings
and such some people can't do that some
people can't do basic math some people
can't make I can't think three moves
ahead not everybody has these abilities
but everybody can vote so when someone
says the milk is just at the store it's
because their logical
capabilities stops one degree from where
they are I go to the store and get milk
what do you mean milk comes from
somewhere else it's at the store
where we think and if this is where you
can't project your your cognitive
faculties onto other people yeah I can
visualize the whole supply chain
from from the birth of the cow I've gone
to the farms and I've I've talked to the
farmers and even I'm not an expert on
this but I certainly understand the milk
at the store came from somewhere from a
truck from a distribution facility from
bottling plant from a farm whatever and
there are people who can't comprehend
that now in the case of Kyle with all
due respect he just had never seen a
farm before my point is not that he's a
stupid person my point is that he is
pushing policy positions and encouraging
votes from a place of extreme ignorance
I am not going to pretend to be the
smartest person in the room or the world
I also do very similar things but I
think you know my point with this is
when it comes to passing Nationwide laws
I think it would be imperative for
people like Kyle to step back and say I
don't know a lot more often yeah and
being intelligent and being you can be
intelligent and be ignorant ignorant
just means you don't know the
information yet or you don't know the
information so Kyle's very intelligent
whether or not he's ignorant about
something you know a lot of people have
things they don't know that's one of the
great wonders of being a human and
that's why I thought it was stupid that
everyone was insulting I'm like dude
Kyle's a nice guy he's like he tries
really hard he's fair to people and uh
back in the day one of the you know one
of one of the reasons I give him a lot
of credit is that he he has consistently
defended Carl Benjamin from all the lies
and the smears of the media when they
were falsely characterizing him as
racist he would reject and be like dude
we don't know don't do that that's not
fair address the arguments and I'm like
this is a good dude but he doesn't know
what a farm looks like that means when
he goes on his channel and says hey guys
you should Vote for This policy in that
policy you you know that he's missing a
huge portion of knowledge in certain
areas I'm not saying he's talking about
voting policy on farms or anything I'm
just saying
yo when people talk about stuff on
Twitter
most people don't know anything yeah
yeah and I mean even in government like
how many people in the U.S department of
Agriculture building in DC right now
have no experience firsthand on a farm
probably a large number yeah true do you
work in the government I don't know do
you spend a lot of time with people to
work in the government yes right by
Capitol Hill is where our office is so
we work with them a lot do you get the
vibe are they a lot of ignorant people
like people that just don't know not
stupid I mean they might be very
intelligent but this that they just are
seeing a lot of information they're
stupid you see stupid people yeah well
there are certainly stupid people
absolutely but I think too it's hard to
be kind of a jack of all trades you're
dealing with a lot of different subject
matter you know whether it's farming ESG
there so you can't be an expert on
everything so that's where you have to
rely on intelligent and capable people
to kind of inform you on different
policy for those issue areas I have to
read this comment from Chaz Warren he
says Tim if you have pushed a prolapsed
uterus back into a cow you can say you
know what the supply chain is like oh
wow
no I went to I went to a bunch of farms
in California and uh talked with us a
group of farmers I actually got a tour
of a farm it was really cool I got to go
to their board room and he explained to
me that even though they were a family
farm of course they have trustees and
board members the family grew it got
bigger they've got distant cousins and
stuff it was really cool got to walk
around the farmer explained to me that
kale became a cash crop for them because
in the 90s it was a garden it was a
decoration and then the hipsters loved
it and now we make tons of money so I
thought that was really funny and then
my favorite experience on the farm was
um when when I realized cows weren't
locked up and I was like the cows are
just out in the field like they're just
eating right here he's like yep and I'm
like what if they leave and the farmer's
like
where would they go
yeah it's like I don't know I don't they
just leave and he's like why would they
leave there's food here and I just
didn't even think of that because I'm
used to like you open the door the dog
runs away you know what I mean but cows
like they're not gonna leave same thing
with chickens man like you you learn
this stuff you open the door the
chickens out chickens aren't going
anywhere they'll wander around they'll
be dumb but they come home you know we
don't we don't want the chickens going
out because they get eaten but cows
that's where the phrase come home to
roost exactly yeah exactly and until the
cows come home I once I was I was
driving and I saw this big trail of cows
and uh I asked farmer one of the one of
the Dairy Farmers about it and he was
like yeah the cows will go off and find
landil Grace they'll hang out then
they'll come back home you know later
when they're done I'm like why
but yes I've never I've never pushed a
prolapsed uterus back into account not
yet
but imagine
2024 is going to be wild though
well we do want to get a cow for a free
Diamond stand yes we might have to get
more than one though because they want
front so yeah just let them well like
goat yeah with goats how in a goat the
thing is you you I think what was it
cows produced like 12 gallons of milk a
day or something is it that much Jesus
yeah 12 that's gallons like wait wait
are you serious one cow that's too much
can't drink all that milk look it up
yeah it's something like that you need a
lot of Hershey syrup yeah see this is
like a dairy cow for just a regular cow
too especially if they're in estrus all
that stuff yeah anyway yeah that's true
that's true 20 to 25 liters a day yeah
it's like six to seven gallons yeah
seven is average wow due to genetic
manipulation and artificial high protein
diets they can produce six to seven nah
we'll just have the cow go around eating
grass we got too much of it so we have
it's really cool about one gallon
natural is just one gallon a day oh okay
all right well that's a lot probably
fine so uh for people who don't live out
in the middle of nowhere there
um I'll explain this a cool thing to you
and for people who do live in the middle
of nowhere you already know this we have
50 acres so we have a deal with a local
farmer he comes and mows all of the wild
grass or whatever bails it up and keeps
it and each bale of I guess I should
call it bale of hay or whatever it's not
a bale of hay it's just whatever is
growing there it's worth like I think
200 to 300 wow so for this guy he's
getting like 20 of these things and all
he has to do is come and take it and
it's his it's a good deal for us we get
the the land taken care of and for the
farmer he gets food for his animals it's
awesome and that that's how it's been
for most of the rural spots that I've
had I'm assuming that's how it works but
let's get back to the cities and talk
about some cultural news we got this
story from CNN you love CNN don't you
pride month backlash hurt Target sales
they fell for the first time in six
years
you know I'm trying to say this real
quick this is partly why they're so
heavily coming after Trump their
cultural Endeavors are failing targets
quarterly sales fell for the first time
in six years and it's uh
as as consumers pulled back on
discretionary goods and fierce
right-wing backlash to their Prime month
collection this Target's stock drops 27
over the past year
there's amazing stuff
culturally
the right is winning
it doesn't necessarily I guess at this
point post-liberals you know former
Liberals are now considered right-wing
with uh a song like rich men north of
Richmond what how many I'm gonna look
this up how many of you 17 million one I
saw seven seven where did you see 17 on
YouTube YouTube yeah
right and then you've got all the
different Twitter videos with 10 million
here you type in Rich and the song pops
up right away Richmond north of Richmond
16 million views in a week wow 16
million views in a week 16.6 million
views amazing I'll some dude singing a
song about corrupt government
failed policies and he's just got a
guitar and he's just singing and it's
nailing it sound of Freedom just passed
Indiana Jones on a small budget they
just did a press release Angel Studios
did a press release saying all of their
investors just got a uh 120 return wow
oh that is awesome
makes sense considering he was a 15
million dollar budget that pulled in on
770 some odd million dollars so I I
think I think that's what the press
release said a hundred let me let me
quadruple check here I'm not sure if it
was 20 on top
like they put in a hundred and I got
like 120.
this is I don't think that it's I don't
think that it's the right wing that's
winning okay so I'm sorry it's their
original investment plus 20 so they got
a 20 return that's still absolutely
fantastic yeah you go to someone and say
I can get you a 20 return in you know in
two years people are gonna that's really
good
especially uh for producing a good movie
on top of it like a good product so you
can feel good about the money that you
made so while those good things are
happening Bud Light Lost 400 million
dollars and what I think it is is it's
the anti-authoritarian movement that's
winning this libertarian movement it's
not necessarily the libertarian party
but it's just libertarian cons
conception people are tired of
authoritarian crap like finding out
about the government like all this
crispr I'm not crisper but like oh the
the prism program the Edward Snowden
blue blue open and like just finding
about all this like totalitarian crap
behind the scenes with the CIA and the
NSA and all this junk since 9 11. people
are tired of that and they're pushing
back against the corporate government
collusion this fascist crap I think kova
did it and they call it right wing but
that's a misnomer man it is people that
just do not want a top-down Authority
commanding our lifestyle and covet had a
huge part to play and that it woke
people up they were forced to look at
things
I think uh the coveted lockdowns did it
for a lot of people
they went nuts and they and there's a
viral video going around now from a dude
who participated in the BLM riots saying
that it was one of the stupidest and
cringiest things he's ever done yeah
because now he's been realizing what's
going on the smartest thing I think I've
heard someone say is to say what can we
do how do we win we always stand the
show like engage in culture build
culture share culture and then someone
said something brilliant on Twitter I
think Mike cernovich retweeted it it was
sell them on Twitter and X
convince them to sign up for it that's
the easiest thing to do because you
don't need to say Trump is good you
don't need to say RFK is good you don't
need to save a fake is good you need to
say DeSantis is good you need only say
hey you should sign up on Twitter and we
can we can chat and share memes and then
they're like oh okay then they'll start
seeing the retweets they'll see the news
Clips they'll see Joe Biden say if you
don't find the prosecutor not get the
billion dollars then they'll see CNN say
it never happened and they'll go what
but I watched that video
that's the thing convince all of your
friends to sign up for x
that's the path x.com
I would like to say oh boy it's so fun I
got paid
I got Elon Musk gave me 100 bucks
because I was complaining about stuff
how fun I was thinking we should have on
the show at some point like somebody
that's deep in the Deep State yeah that
wants to talk about it there must be
somebody that's like tell us why because
you guys are listening right now why do
you think it's a why is it good why is
this I understand like you don't want
terrorism you don't want Timothy McVeigh
to get unlimited amounts of electricity
so that he does the most giant explode
like I understand that but like what
aspect of like trying to clamp down do
you think is better for our society as a
whole I just I want to know I want to
talk about it I can explain it probably
in a rudimentary way that lacks a lot of
information and I'll explain it like
this
Lil Luke and Roberto don't get along
we go in we separate them and we lock up
Roberto Jr he does not know why we don't
care if he knows why we just want him to
do what we want him to do because we
want eggs
and that's it and we want to be able to
make more of the chickens later on
the chickens are probably sitting there
being like they're coming here and
separating us one chicken's like they're
stealing our children and eating them
and they're like oh here they go with
egg gate again
omelet gate no one's stealing your
babies and eating them that's an insane
conspiracy there chicken
is it my point is
these people in the Deep State they
don't care what you have to say they
don't care what I have to say they care
only that their machine functions in the
way they want to function like a chicken
coop they wake up in the morning there's
fresh eggs they get to eat them in their
mind it's the machine operates they get
big penthouses they get to control
military power power over the world all
over the world and they don't want to
deal with China pushing back on them in
some instances they are working with
China I think the reality is the world
economic Forum Western Powers NATO
Europe and the U.S found out that very
quickly the Chinese Communist method was
preferable so there is a conflict
between the west and China but these wef
Elites and many prominent position
people in the U.S politics would prefer
a Chinese Communist system in the United
States I was just listening James
Lindsay on Josie redheaded Libertarians
uh X space on last Sunday and James was
explaining like it's come to the point
where these terms neo-fascist Communists
Neo this let's don't use the word Neo
just call it communist but even then
it's like when you really ask these guys
that are trying like what do you want
your new government to be there like you
know what I don't even care as long as
my son is on top they don't so it you
know it's Goblin King at this point it's
just people who use power to gain power
and screw everybody else that's why you
see people running to the streets
smashing cars breaking into stores
stealing whatever they want because it's
raw power time yeah and they're afraid
of any institution that would threaten
that like you know the traditional
family unit or nationhood and being
proud of your country and being you know
bonded to your fellow countrymen they're
afraid of those forces so they've sought
to suppress them that's why when you
have someone like naive Kelly or Donald
Trump who is a nationalist figure they
yell fascism at them and try to use
every Force they can to cancel them and
to silence them because they are scared
of those forces because they threaten
their power because a family collected
with other families could be more
powerful a nation can be more powerful
than them and that's that's scary to
them what do you think of naive
bouquelli the president
I think he has saved his country
absolutely I mean he single-handedly
wiped out the most satanic gangs in the
western hemisphere in one foul swoop and
now El Salvador is becoming a wonderful
place to live again it's a safe place to
live businesses are going there it's
incredible what did he do with the car
cartels is that what they were what did
he do like when was it what I saw like
three four weeks ago that they mobilized
like their their military and like
surrounded a bunch of stuff was that
were you talking about like in one in
one moment he had them all taken or
something yeah they've had a couple mass
operations where they've gone and got
these gangsters
um but yeah he's locked them up and you
know you hear folks in the western media
complain about due process and things
like that but when you have a country
that is so destitute and with such
rampant crime you have to be aggressive
and you have to use force in order to
restore order and he has had the guts to
do that a lot of people don't
so maybe so there you think there are
people in the United States that have
that mentality that they're like we have
to use Force because they think it's
that bad or they're being led to believe
it's that bad I think so yeah I mean I
don't think we're quite at else where El
Salvador was when naibu Kelly you know
took power and cleaned it up but I think
we're certainly getting there and I
think when you don't have order when you
have complete chaos that can you know
lend itself to mob Justice and things
like that and and a strong man
um so obviously that's not something
that we necessarily want in this country
but if the right individual does it as
naive has done for El Salvador it can be
you know it can restore order and it can
let your countrymen achieve Prosperity
again had it been chaotic in El Salvador
oh yeah their murder rate was some of
the worst in the western world
and now it's safer than most American
cities within over the course of like a
year yes geez yeah it's incredible like
I said I was hanging out at uh I was at
MGM a couple months ago playing poker of
all things and there was a dude who you
know you when you're there you're
hanging out you're talking to people he
mentioned that uh he was leaving soon
and I was like I was like oh you're
leaving the states and he's like yeah
I'm going to El Salvador and I was like
oh really he's like I'm from there but
my family left but now we're going back
and then I was like oh wow why he's like
oh it got really better really good now
it's safe
crazy people who had left the country to
move the United States now want to go
back also people complain about him
being you know a dictator and things
like that CNN MSNBC all those folks but
he's actually totally wiped out
corruption in his country he's limited
government more than any Republican
president in recent memory he's totally
shrunk you know all of the power that
the legislature was abusing and he's
really kind of just wiped out the swamp
in many ways is he like uh he was
elected and then so do they does he have
a term limit I'm actually not sure
not sure about El Salvador I got that
kind of vibe in New York I didn't wasn't
there in the 80s but in I got to New
York in the early 2000s and by that
point I guess Giuliani had cleaned it up
like it was apparently hell on Earth in
the 80s and then that guy's financially
ruined now yeah it's crazy well they I
think you know the powers that bee don't
want you to know that you can do what
naibu Kelly did or what Rudy Giuliani
did like we don't have to accept this
decline or this chaos we can totally
reinstitute order we just have Elites
currently that are unwilling to do it
because they have no interest in that
right they love this lawlessness it lets
them kind of do their deep State work
with while no one's noticing and it
oppresses people too right it's
dehumanizing almost to live in these
American cities that are rampant with
crime that are totally deteriorated they
want to keep your spirit down
yeah the you mean the leadership does
yeah yes
yeah because then your life sucks real
life sucks every day like you get on go
down to like the street you go to the
shop and then someone's stealing
everything and you're like oh well I've
got all this money I'm gonna spend it on
this food this guy just took it over for
free do you really like demoralizes you
at a deep level after a little while you
know
yeah yeah you feel like things are
beginning to fall apart yeah and then
you're not you're less willing to like
work for the system and then make it all
work out well it's it's it's it's also
simply this things get so chaotic people
eventually just say for what reason am I
risking my health and safety for this
yep I'm gonna just do my own thing and
they give up they said I would rather
just plug myself back into the Matrix
and eat the steak and ignore all the
problems to think that American
leadership would let that happen just
because like I I want to think that
they're overwhelmed and they can't stop
it or they feel incapable well not that
they want it to happen so that they can
strike with their with their Patriot Act
but but like current leadership wanted
to happen because if you don't want to
go vote then it'd be easier for them to
potentially you know get get their
person than they would like in in power
in power if you don't go vote do you
think that the US has like become like a
political autocracy do you feel that way
I I I don't know it's a good question
you mean
here's a question for you
there's a lot of people who are saying
that we live in a simulation a lot of
these AI guys genuinely believe that we
live in a simulation they've tweeted
about it where they're like base reality
what was the Tweet the guy said base
reality happened only one time and this
is not it or whatever what if
he was wondering if he even existed ever
existed in base reality or whatever
whatever humans destroy the planet with
pollution not like the Matrix with
robots but like let's just say that the
world becomes crap it's garbage there's
Mass pollution you struggle to breathe
you're thin and frail there's no food
it's overpopulated so everybody plugs in
to the simulation where you live this
life instead
would you choose to leave this
fake reality of comfort knowing that
real base reality was horrifying and
painful oh
why why would you well are we able to
help base reality from this is the
question about politics in general it's
it's a Sci-Fi analogy for would you
choose to engage in politics what is it
better to be a fisherman than to engage
in the politics of man or whatever that
was uh that was uh from the French
Revolution that was what was his name
the number two guy the French Revolution
better be a poor farmer than to engage
in the politics of man and he's
basically saying just give in he's like
I shouldn't have done he's like if I
could do it all over again I wouldn't
have gotten involved the reason I
disagree with that mentality is
let's say that we'll use the Sci-Fi
analogy of being in a pod in a matrix
one day all of a sudden you start oh you
start coughing up blood and you're like
what's happening I don't know what's
going on and then all of a sudden you go
blind in one eye and you're like you
start shrieking and screaming and then
in base reality there's a guy
bludgeoning your pod with a with a
mallet screaming and you can't see it
and you can't stop it and you can't do
anything about it that's how I view
politics there are a lot of people like
who cares just ignore it's like yes and
then one day a mob shows up and burns
down your house and you never saw it
coming you're ill prepared for it and
now you have to suffer the consequences
in the worst ways imaginable and uh for
those that were prepared and built a
little bunker with beans or something
they escaped long before it happened or
has a strong Community or a strong
Community but though right those who
prepared for the catastrophe before it
happened are probably going to be okay
like if a zombie apocalypse were to
break out and they're a group of people
that were warning of it happening and
they built Big walls around their
neighborhood and stocked up on supplies
for 30 years when that happens they're
gonna be people screaming let us in and
they're gonna be like nope but the thing
about about simulation theory is that
you can impact base reality from the
simulation so yeah you could you could
fight the the AI in the simulation and
Destroy its ability to function in the
simulation that's like a weird thing you
made up dude I don't think so if you
were if you like if you're in like when
you play Skyrim can you while playing on
Playstation alter the code and change
what the AI does what happens in Skyrim
is affecting me in reality like I get
angry if the dragon kills my guy in
Skyrim so nothing else you can affect
politics without paying attention to
politics
you playing that video game have no
impact on the outside world other than
just you playing the video game but you
understand what I mean like you don't
need to be in you don't need to be
engaged in a politics to influence
politics like you can have no idea
what's going on but make the best song
on Earth and everyone just drives that
has nothing to do with base reality or
whatever I see what you're saying about
engaging in culture in ways that are not
political yes but but you have to like
Richmond north of Richmond I I I assume
that if I sat down with Oliver Anthony
he's gonna be able to he will have a
conversation about politics clearly he
knows what's going on for him to write a
song about what's going on so he's in
The Fray he's not hiding from it
otherwise he'd written some weird love
song or he'd write a song about his
truck and his dog on his way to work I
hope he has them it probably does That's
Country 101 right yeah so like would you
see for me in the Matrix like Morpheus
went in and was like hey Neo snap out of
it and so he went into the Matrix to
alter base reality from within the
Matrix so if you could go be like a
matrix Warrior and just be in this like
Fantasyland and still somehow impact
people that's like the life of an artist
maybe where you don't even touch
politics but you have to I mean here's
the funny thing Taylor Swift one of the
most politically influential
personalities in the world she wrote
that song about how everyone should be
gay or whatever and you shouldn't be mad
about it I'm exaggerating a little bit
but uh what is it called you need you
need to calm down or something yeah yeah
and like in the song it just
caricaturizes and insults people on the
right who are you know opposed to gay
marriage and things like that
so she's influenced a massive generation
of young kids to agree with her because
they're Fanatics and then if they do
unplug they've already got that
brainwash from with that they learned
while they were in the simulation
so I'm kind of a simulation Warrior
personally I love being seen anywhere
yeah I like being in the game I like
being part of the fun and kind of
tweaking people's subconscious without
overtly displaying the data I found that
to be very effective for for many years
but I also it's important to snap out of
it it's dark and dirty but somebody's
got to do it you know it's really funny
just like one day Ian wakes up and he's
in a neural link simulation and they
were like the whole purpose of the
simulation was that you didn't believe
in God and so he ran this you know
50-year 50-year life existence for you
to hear the arguments I assume even God
when I was a little now I do that's so
weird and then you wake up and you're
like what happened and they're like you
believe in God and you've you've
defeated simulations you believe in God
yes what do you think it is well do I
think that it is the creator of the
universe
I believe that Christ is King and Lord
like how did it create what like what do
you how deep do you go on how it creates
the universe
I mean I think that
you know no one really knows because no
one was there I do believe in the
biblical creation story
um and I think you know if God decided
to utilize some sort of cosmic event
perhaps you did so he said let there be
light and there was light so maybe it
was some sort of massive Cosmic event a
big bang something like that who knows
um but yeah I mean I don't think that
all of this you look at the intricacies
of nature how ordered and organized
everything is I don't think it came from
nothing it was accidental yeah like
there's no time the time scale I don't
think there's time in relative to God so
like all these like you might think some
some meteor coming is just like some
random occurrence but I feel like he it
he whatever sets things in motion that
might take hundreds of millions or
billions of years to arrive and then but
it's all part of this like plan
and so maybe that's why I'm thinking
about this this
comic I love this comic it's so good so
uh for those that are just listening
I'll have to explain it it says silica
gel do not eat and the guy goes those
silica gel industry Big Shots can't tell
me what to do and then he throws in his
mouth the next one is a picture of him
with a weird cap on his head and wires
and he's shocked and two scientists then
say congratulations you've escaped the
simulation Welcome to the Real World
do not eat silica gel please if it says
don't eat it don't eat it but that's
just a really funny comic I don't know
why this guy thought of it it was just
hilarious what would you do Tim if you
were if you found out you were in a
simulation if Morpheus came to you and
offered you a tough question uh I'd ask
for information on base reality and I'd
ask for information about the simulation
is and why it exists and whatever I
would make the immediate assumption that
the existence of a simulation and Us in
it is a Bad Thing depends on if we are
base reality beings that are plugged
into a simulation or AI generated
simulated beings in which case we can't
leave the simulation anyway
but if it was a matrix type scenario and
a guy like Morpheus came to me and said
you can take the blue bill or you could
take the red pill I'd be like well you
got to tell me what's going on out there
first like I I know what's going on here
this is in existence I comprehend and
understand you tell me I take this pill
and I go somewhere else explain to me
what that's what's somewhere else Alex
Jones did on Joe Rogan's podcast uh
interdimensional space aliens man it's
the dancing machine elves they're
bouncing they're coiling in and out
infinitely didn't you say like
interdimensional like sounds like a song
vampires or something like that you know
what he said he did say there were
demons there were evil ones yeah that's
you said some more stuff but yeah have
you ever break through on DMT
I don't think Kingsley has ever done DMT
I haven't really I've never broken
through I want to I've like puffed on it
in the past shattering the veil yeah
breaking through you know what was it
breaking the veil I can imagine like
apparently your arms go out and then
they go out forever in every direction
you your feet go forever like you just
see the fractal repetition forever in
every in every direction and it's
terrifying yeah like it breaks reason
but maybe we need to do that or humans
benefit can benefit from breaking
The Logical you know oh no man
three-dimensional maybe maybe we are all
pieces of the universe experiencing
itself
and that's it
I do believe that like because of the
fact that we're conscious we are the
like the universe's Consciousness like
your knees aren't conscious right your
liver is not conscious yeah but so I
don't think we're the end-all be-all of
Consciousness I think we're microscopic
and relative to the potential potentials
of consciousness
uh uh I mean I'm not quite sure what
you're saying uh human consciousness is
extremely small right like yeah you're
like look at a dog's Consciousness a
dog's mental state there's something
greater than humans obviously or I think
mathematically but I wonder if the next
phase of of life is going to be AI
so to use like uh
Marvel as an example the celestial
beings these you know ego is a planet
what happens when humans
create nanotechnology
and industrialize the point of
automation where you have an AI that can
create more of itself
it doesn't need humans anymore to
facilitate it
then the planet becomes a big machine
that then absorbs other planets and gets
bigger and bigger and becomes this
massive powerful construct or whatever
yeah I was thinking maybe a couple days
ago the AI oh what was that paperclip
machine yeah that's a great that's a
that's a game you can play on the
internet um and you just but I I always
think you consume things and then turn
them into paperclipses the whole
universe is Big AI needs us I think it
needs us to propagate so it wants a
machine I can't tell for sure it might
get to a point where it can subsist
without us but I feel like it's
synergistic with AI let's hope not let's
hop on same time soon let's let that let
that simmer well whatever happens it'll
be long uh past the time we die so yeah
true all right let's go to super chats
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends it really does help and of
course as election season is heating up
people are starting to notice that the
show isn't appearing anymore on their
home pages and they're even having a
hard time finding it so sharing it
really really does up post it on X post
it on Facebook or wherever you can and
uh head over to timcast.com click join
us at members only shows come coming up
in about a half an hour but let's read
I'm not your guy friend says I watched
Alan dershowitz's podcast from yesterday
and he gave a lesson on what the RICO
statute is and how it's being abused in
Trump's case I need a Phil yell
yes well there you go
that was worth every penny
cultural culture abduction says good
news North Carolina passed a ban on
gender affirming care for minors uh
excuse me what did they what did they
ban
let me let me rephrase this for you good
news North Carolina passed a ban on
child sex changes
uh and Tran and biological males
competing in in female sports leagues
this is truly based let the leftist
tears flow love the show and everything
y'all do yo choppy chubby had to correct
some of that Marxist neo-linguistics you
were using there sir sorry
friend says here's a couple bucks just
to hear Ian Crowe again
this is Roberto Jr by the way I love
that guy
I honestly don't think that's what he
said
it would go down and then he'd like try
and keep it up but you didn't have it
you know I wonder how many people just
turned the TV off all right they paid
for one not three
[Laughter]
Goldilocks production says if DeSantis
allows them to take Trump from his State
any chance of him regaining my respect
goes with campaign chances this whole
situation will spark a hot conflict the
dams aren't going too far
I think they want a hot conflict I think
they they feel like they're losing Trump
won the first time and they were
surprised it happened they had to go
insane covid it's the only way they were
able to win second time and now they
don't think they're gonna win again they
need some kind of conflict otherwise
they have no path for it Democrats know
if they instigate the violence they lose
so they need other people to start it I
know that if we stay the course we get
Scott Pressler to ramp up his efforts
with 100 new Scott presslars if we keep
winning in the cultural fronts with
things like sound of Freedom with Bud
Light failing with Target failing you
know the the the where we're going is
inevitable liberals leftists they're
aborting their kids they're sterilizing
their kids big business Disney is losing
hundreds of millions nearly a billion
dollars Bud Light Lost 400 million
dollars Target lust 27 stock value
they're clearly losing in all of the
cultural areas
nothing but good news so what do they do
they go after Trump because they want
you to think you've lost already when
you're winning don't forget it
let's go big Buddha says Tim having to
do some searching for your shows you
know it's election season is Trump's
indictment the end of the Republic as we
know it seems like an irreversible
precedent being set rip Roberto Jr I
think that it is indicative of
some kind of Civil War as I've stated
before
but I think that it can easily be
averted if we stay the course in winning
the culture War culture will then
dictate what is permissible I think the
actions Democrats are taking are so
extreme it's going to result in people
refusing to vote for Democrats
it doesn't mean they'll vote for trump
it means that they're going to be alike
this is crazy I don't have anything to
do with this it means you're going to
come to people and you're going to be
like I know Trump is bad but I mean look
at all the indictments the race are
getting crazy like it's it's getting out
of hand and people are going to be like
jeez
you're getting to the point where people
say to the Democrats just shut up
already I don't care anymore and then
that indifference results in Trump
winning
there's no guarantee that Trump does get
revenge or fixes anything but it's a
start
we'll see what happens in 2024 because I
don't see the Democrats just forgetting
if they lose
I certainly don't see Trump supporters
are forgetting if they lose either for
the time being though I think we're in a
decent spot even if they are going after
Trump so long as Trump plays the right
cards whatever those cards may be
let's grab some more Super chats graft
he says buck buck people LOL I'm dumb
well that's unfortunate
Gabriel William Paul hey Tim I'm meeting
my cousin's husband for the first time
tomorrow he was recently on the cover of
a very famous magazine for his company's
work with crispr technology going to be
worth billions wow what should I ask him
I don't know Ian what do you think we
should ask him
um oh can you genetically engineer
people so they don't have to breathe or
that they can breathe every minute can
you or make them see super far alter
someone's genes slowly over time so that
their bodies slowly changes into
something else
so I'd imagine what you'd have to do is
you would have to create
DNA with minor changes that don't cause
your body to fail and so what I'm saying
is like turn someone's hair you know
Brown again from white or eyes blue from
brown or something or vice versa how
long would it take
and is it possible I'd imagine they use
viruses you know they'll like put the
new genetics in the virus I imagine it's
possible but but at present technology I
have to imagine that it would be like
every week you get a new slightly
updated virus
to alter your genetics and it would take
over seven years to fully change
everything
crazy huh
but then you're uh you know you you you
it's literally not the same person would
you guys do genetic therapy for anything
sure I heard they can regrow teeth oh
hell yeah yeah there's like research on
memory growing teeth yeah yes crazy stem
cells maybe my teeth need work I wonder
if I could genetic alterations so my
muscles develop faster and bigger and
stronger oh I read something interesting
um and people who are listening let me
know what you think yeah I read that you
drink a protein shake before bed okay do
that tonight yeah so uh no sugar
and you it says to aim for like
less than 100 calories total and if you
do 30 to 40 grams of protein just before
bed then your body uh it causes muscle
growth it speeds up muscle muscle
protein muscle protein synthesis the
protein that I take is uh isopure and
it's just protein so there's no carbs in
it so that helps you monitor your Macros
a little bit better you can get that and
mix that with water and it's just the
calories from the protein just whey
protein zero carbs doesn't taste great
when you mix it with water but it does
dissolve pretty well take that right
before you go I recommend the Jocko milk
I'm not saying that's the only way to go
if there's there's it's less than one
gram of carbs per scoop 22 grams of
protein it's got monk fruit sweetener
which is allulose so it's an it's not an
artificial sweetener it's a it's a fruit
extract that tastes sweet but your body
does not uh process it just like sugar
just gets rid of it Jaco willink you're
talking about yeah okay he's got his own
protein uh because we were talking about
this before I bought I think it's called
the gold standard or something and it's
got Splenda it's got sucralose in it I'm
like ah it's gross yeah I don't I don't
care about that I will I will I will eat
a block of like you know Ian's got the
naked way it's just pure way yeah like
give me that I don't care but then I
looked up you know no Splenda and the
Jocko stuff came up and uh it's got like
seven ingredients or whatever and it is
the best tasting I've had I see I'm
looking at isopure right now they've got
a vegan stuff too Taylor Silverman if
you're listening she's vegan looking for
a good protein there you go plant-based
I gotta tell you man
uh I do not get enough protein I was not
getting enough protein it's crazy so
I've been skating more and I skate and I
get super sore and then I'm like man
that kind of sucks you know my recovery
takes forever and then I looked up how
much protein it's at a sedentary person
on average needs like 40 to 60 grams of
protein yeah and I'm like dude I'm
getting like 30 to 40 per day that's it
and I'm not sedentary I skate it's like
no wonder so I bought the the protein
didn't like it about the Jocko protein
now I have a protein shake within a half
an hour of completing the workout nice
and
almost no recovery time I wake up the
next day feeling like a million bucks
the best thing you can do if you if you
notice that like you're sore after you
exercise and stuff at a meal add a meal
and make sure it's a high protein meal
that's the best way to to make sure that
your your soreness goes away as fast as
possible make sure that your body has
the building blocks to repair the muscle
damage that you do well so uh C win says
casein protein not whey protein why why
is that why not weigh uh I had a I had a
weight it seems like a slower burn right
is that what it is I'm not 100 sure the
difference in case in a way I know what
is is uh is from milk usually so is
casein yeah is it I had a uh I had a
chocolate milk before bed and I woke up
feeling better than I felt in a very
very long time that was crazy
feeling like a lightning surging I was
like Wow Jocko's the man yeah he's cool
dude and and uh
man impressive I really love the getting
rid of the garbage chemicals out of food
that's happening yeah I don't know if
seed oils are bad but I appreciate
anybody getting stuff out of food that
shouldn't be there if I want to eat a
steak I want the ingredients to be steak
we've got the carnivore snacks jerky
ingredients beef salt works for me you
know I don't even think it needs a salt
I will eat it with just a fat and a beef
partly why I'm into stem cell meat
because the cow you don't know what it's
been eating its whole life you don't
know all that feces that is passing
through it and like all that junk that
is involved with that meat so like grow
it in a lab you know the exactly what's
in it exactly what the life has been for
that piece of yeah people are saying
casein is slow release so have that
before bed the Jocko stuff says time to
release or something on it but I'll
definitely pick up some case and stuff
do you do protein chicks I've done
casein power before and shakes usually
in the morning I probably should do it
at night it sounds like
I'm gonna I'm gonna write that down
because I'm gonna order some literally
once we rap yeah dude yeah let's do the
digestion time is what it seems like
really casing takes a longer time like
maybe it says Slow Burn and then um wave
proteins pretty quick from what I
understand right after workout casing
comes from the word K scene from Latin
meaning cheese ah there you go all right
let's grab some more what do we got
curtilingus that's a good name says Tim
several months ago I saw one of your
music videos as a YouTube ad I was
shocked I can't remember what the song
was the video was animated what was the
song I can't find it anywhere the song
is called will of the people and it's
because when we made that music video we
just we didn't really think about what
we were doing with music so we just
uploaded it to this channel
so if you search YouTube for Tim cast
will of the people you'll find it and
now all of the new music appears on the
Tim cast music YouTube channel
and uh I think someone else actually
asked about uh
arm uh what's going on with them oh here
we go Matthew Schneider says hey Tim
when is your next song coming out
looking forward to it let me know if you
need an alto saxophone player I can
improvise and play every major scale
sure I mean perhaps saxophone wicked
cool yeah Alto too yeah I like saxophone
um the next music video is coming out
probably very soon I think in the next
couple of weeks is that the one we're
working on yeah well we'll finish
shooting it in two weeks a week and a
half and then I the post I think it's
gonna take about a month in post tough
to say exactly but it's there's stuff
being done in the video now but the
reason this one's taking a lot longer is
because first at for the music video Ian
stopped eating and drinking for a couple
days
filmed the scene filmed act three then
started eating and working out
got better more you know filled back out
and uh filmed act two and now Ian is
working out and eating a lot more and
then we'll film act one so that in the
music video he's actually slowly
disintegrating and getting weaker and
frailer and it was one first order I
didn't eat for a couple days I was down
to 127 pounds when we shot the end of
the thing and I was miserable it was
like method acting like I truly was that
miserable character you see in the music
video it's incredible so the it's gonna
be it's gonna be good
we'll see yeah you know month and a half
yeah and then and then we already do
have the next song after that
um nearing completion but the music
video I don't know it will be and then
we'll see where we go after that but we
just you know we're chilling with it I'm
not trying to force stuff up I I you
know that people a lot of people are
resistant to overtly political songs and
so most of the stuff that we put out is
not political this one is passively
political it has a message we'll see how
much people care and then I think we're
we're getting close to political season
and we've got a couple political songs
you can you can write political songs
that like people don't really that don't
people don't feel like they're being
preached at like there's a song on on
the fall of ideals that's literally like
I I I'm kind of nervous to say this
because the left leftist might get an
idea but it's a very it's very
anti-fascist like intentionally
specifically says I will not fall I will
not fall down to fascist beliefs or
whatever it's like and it's legitimately
an anti-fascist song and no one would
know because I'm not sitting there being
like you got to do this and you got to
do that blah blah blah you know so so
yeah I love a million to one I think it
is political in that it's like a David
versus Goliath kind of feeling like that
you know citizen versus this government
Goliath thing that you think you can't
handle this international government and
like that's kind of what it's about yeah
and it that's what I was getting from it
today while I was thinking about it
singing about it kind of I think the
song is basically about people who claim
that it's impossible to succeed and
anybody who succeeds is the exception
not the rule when in reality that's not
true
it's but it's both true and not you at
the same time the people who succeed are
technically the exception because
there's very few who succeed but it's
because they chose to succeed they
worked really really hard and they found
their path and they never gave up the
basic idea is when they they did these
studies about what is the determining
factor in success they found the only
thing that matter was perseverance yeah
that no matter how many times you failed
you kept working at it and there are
people who are wealthy and failed and
gave up and they they're not successful
and they're people who are poor who
never gave up who became successful and
people who are poor who gave up in loss
and people who are rich or who had
perseverance and became successful I got
kicked out of a band and then I started
All That Remains and then I tried out
for another band and didn't get it both
of those bands and the odds like went on
to be very big bands and All That
Remains took a couple records to get
ourselves off the ground but like I
didn't stop just because I got kicked
out of a band what bands do you talk
about it publicly yeah I was in band I
was in a band called Shadows Fall and
then I tried out for a band called
Killswitch Engage and uh this guy Howard
Jones got the job for kill switch so wow
doesn't kill switch yeah I feel that I
flew out and filled in for kill switch
for a month they called me they called
me in the middle night Adam's like can
you get on a plane tomorrow and I'm like
can you get my dog to DC because at the
time I was married and I had my dog and
my ex-wife was in DC and they they got
the dog to DC and I got on a plane flew
down to California and did a month of
touring with Killswitch Engage on 24
hours notice imagine if you got kicked
out of that band and you were like and
you went to AMC and applied to be a
theater manager instead I mean the
reason All That Remains the reason is
all that remain the reason All That
Remains is successful is because y'all
ain't gonna kick me out and then me fail
that was the re like I wasn't gonna be
the guy that failed like I wasn't gonna
be like because there was a bunch of
bands from my area that were getting
signed and going off and doing stuff and
I was like I'm not gonna be the dude
that gets left behind while all my
friends go off and and you know live
their dream as a rock stars and and I
just don't do it I'm not gonna quit I'm
not gonna stop I'm gonna start another
band and do it and
and I was talking about this earlier I
once I've been homeless several times
and I once lived in a band space that
cost 100 bucks a month it was literally
just a room probably about twice the
size of this and there was nothing else
that it was drywall and wood wood ply
board separating you from the other
rooms and there's a single shared
bathroom and uh we had uh uh discarded
van seats that we got from the side of
the road to sleep on and it was just get
just get you out of the weather outside
right yeah just keep give you something
to have overhead a bit of running water
I mean I could have just went and did
menial labor or some other nonsense
there's something so freeing about that
and you can tend to do your I do some of
it my best creative work when I'm in
those like sparse conditions you know
what a lot of it is hey you better do
some because you ain't got nothing
going on so you it's motivating to go do
some stuff you know one week more
freedom too because like nothing's on
the line so you can be risky because you
have nothing to lose yeah exactly once
we get the new space set up we should do
a big show if you guys are interested in
playing if we can get the band we can
get the band if I can get everybody in
the same place at the same time yeah
we'll just we'll do this I have a great
trick to pull that off yeah I'll offer
them money there you go dollars dollars
help dollars all right think on this as
regarding Trump must be guilty of
something Ben Shapiro today said that
Trump literally said look at this
classified document but I thought it was
obvious it was an article T was talking
about is there another instance or is
Ben just guilty as fox in in in dieting
um I don't know what Ben said I know
that there's an audio recording where
Trump is like he's like look at this you
know this story I could have
Declassified this you know but I didn't
and uh what people are pointing out is
that Trump was talking to reporters
probably pulled up a news a printout of
a news story that said Millie claimed he
tried to stop Trump from bombing Iran or
something and that Trump said he should
have Declassified the story behind it
but they can make the context to
whatever they want it to be
that's the manipulation in the lies I'll
give you an example of how they
manipulate context the Ronda Sanders
campaign took a clip that was that was
shot and filmed by alad eliyahu who is a
reporter for timcast they took that clip
and did nothing else and put on it paid
for by Ron DeSantis
I then said they tagged the video paid
for by Rhonda santis DeSantis supporters
then put a community note on my video
saying advertisements must label as per
FEC rules to make it seem like what I
was actually saying is that there was a
full two minute long ad
that included my clip the timcast clip
that Rhonda santis labeled the whole
video on when in fact what I was saying
was they posted only our clip with it
wasn't an ad the video was not an ad and
they used a fact check to alter the
context behind it because you couldn't
actually watch the video that's the
manipulation
so in terms of what Trump said it sounds
like he picked up a story and said look
at this you know look at this right here
he's like oh I could have Declassified
that because he's just speaking in
generalities he's not saying that was
classified but they use it to claim
there he was showing classified
documents it's a manipulation and they
didn't indict Trump over that story
which I think also proves he didn't have
the document they were they were
manipulating what Trump actually said
that's not technically one of the
indictments it's not he was not indicted
on on that on that document yeah which
is which again implies
he was literally so we knew from the
first in the first place that they said
the boxes Trump had included epoxy had
included magazine and newspaper
clippings then you get this audio and
it's like oh so was that the newspaper
clipping he had I don't know what he's
holding up and saying look at this they
want you to assume
don't get manipulated like that
Ryan job says pissing off Nintendo with
playing pirated SSBB and watching three
hours of news entertainment of a place
literally on the other side of the
planet surprisingly this is a moment
where there is nothing I would be more
happy to do
Super Smash Brothers Super Smash Bros
what's the second B Battlegrounds Super
Smash Brothers Brawl brawl yeah what is
that is that the new one or bro that's
the old one right I think yeah it's
after melee so yeah and melee was the
best yeah yeah you know what I really
hate about video games they'll
accidentally make a really amazing
feature that was a bug I think with uh
with melee it was wave dashing yeah and
then they're like well better get rid of
that really fun thing that made it a
skill game
and then everyone gets mad because it's
actually what makes the game fun we are
canceling from Halo 2. yeah you used to
be able to do a hit and and you could
cancel the the animation so that you
could recover faster and shoot and kill
someone like it felt it seemed like one
motion yeah a bunch of shooter games
have reload canceling yep so like so I
think
this could be a destiny I I don't I
don't remember I don't know but one of
the examples was like the reload
animation took a couple seconds but if
if right at a certain point when the
reload happens you switch weapons the
reload is complete and you stuff like
that
Street Street Fighter 2 combos were an
accident and people were yeah combos
were an accident no I did not know that
that was a bug it was a glitch you
weren't supposed to be able to string
moves together perfectly that would
result in uh beating your opponent yeah
with no chance to block or break and
then people first complained and they
were like yo he just did three moves
there was no opportunity for me to even
do anything and then they were like that
that's feature it's called the combo and
bison psych I think M bison and Ryu had
some nasty bison was supposed to be uh
balrog yeah Vega was bison and uh uh no
bison was Vega and Vega was Bell Road it
was uh it was because Mike Tyson's uh
yes it was gonna be M Tyson but they
couldn't get his right so they said M
bison and then they said we're gonna sue
you anyway they moved the name to the
bat the end boss instead of the amazing
I love that
let's grab some more Super chats
uh Ryan tips is for some reason for the
longest time I had to go to a different
web browser to see the show I was using
a VPN in that browser but I never had
any problem with any other videos at the
time interesting
no idea
big dan t says I am a circuit clerk in
West Virginia the procedure of this
whole GA thing is very strange the early
post of the indictment tells me that the
jury was either fixed or did not even
matter
yeah like like the great injury yeah
they said it was an accident and then
the girl said she accidentally hit send
instead of say first they said it was a
fictitious document then they said it
was actually it was a sample then she
said the woman accidentally hit send
instead of save
uh-huh the bigger the story the bigger
they lie they say right yeah
a Siri design says the Supreme Court has
been oddly quiet lately
interesting well they're out of session
aren't they
yeah
Paulie's shortcut says Tim Newsome
resuscitates Joe what if Trump at
Mar-A-Lago and Ron arms up with navy
buddies state law enforcement and guard
would you vote for him if Don gives his
Blessing
if Don Donald Trump
goes to Mar-A-Lago and then goes on TV
and says I will surrender when they
serve documents to law enforcement in
Florida confirming the charges and the
time and date of surrender
if Ron DeSantis then says on TV
when asked Mr Governor did you receive
the charging documents from Georgia
requesting extradition if Ron goes we
did I received them and I crumpled them
up and threw them in the trash next
question then I'd be like okay that
guy's that guy's back on my list I just
don't see him doing something like that
but that would be really really big
here here's here's my question with all
of this
let's say Donald Trump goes to
Mar-A-Lago
you have to serve people you can't just
go on CNN and be like I just like you
all to know that I'm suing philabonti
and he has to be in court tomorrow and
it's like but what is what that's not a
legal serving of anything like there's
there's no way that's legal no so uh
this woman what's her name Fanny Fanny
Willis Fanny Willis she goes on TV and
says they have 10 days to surrender okay
what she's actually saying is their the
law enforcement of Georgia has to send
legal notice to Trump
where is he
you can't just be like he's been in that
he's got 10 days it's like what if what
if you're in Alaska you know what I mean
like what if Trump was on vacation in
the Bahamas and he comes back in three
weeks he doesn't even know he's been
indicted yeah making a TV show doesn't
guarantee they even saw it or anything
exactly it's not a legal process to bet
if he went on TV and exclaimed it so
Trump should have known better so let's
say Trump goes to Florida and says I've
not seen the documents I've not seen any
charges I've heard on TV the same thing
as everybody else but legal process due
process requires a legal service
I await that legal service at my home
which I will gladly respond to when I
receive
what are they gonna do Georgia is going
to send gbi into Florida they have no
jurisdiction that they can't they'd have
to contact Florida government and say
hey we have an indictment for Donald
Trump Rhonda Sanders could then be like
shove it up your ass
if if he does that that and he then I
mean look I'm pissed off about the Deep
State the Deep fake thing but it's not
like he can't remedy that in other ways
if he did something like that I'd be
very very happy
but we'll see we will see
I have no idea I think Trump will Just
Surrender I think he's going to go there
but I mean they're they're going to put
him in jail we'll get the mug shot this
time I'm excited for the T-shirt I think
they're gonna I think there's a high
probability they were manned Trump to
custody
because Jack Smith already made the
argument that Trump is a Flight Risk
so yeah so I would not be surprised if
they go there and argue to the judge
that Donald Trump should not be allowed
to leave as he is the most serious
Flight Risk of any candidate and the
severity the RICO charges
I have a feeling they say yes
also the process is the punishment they
want to inflict maximum embarrassment
and harassment on these individuals
Rudy cassone says Camp is supposed to be
Republican these are State charges why
is there no pressure on him to Pardon
it's a pardon board in Georgia not uh
the governor doesn't can't just do it he
the governor appoints a pardon board who
can then make these decisions or
whatever but so unfortunately can't
remove the prosecutor because it's a
commission that does that as well yeah
I think Georgia is a very very deeply
corrupt state and I have to wonder
maybe the reason Kemp is going after
Trump is because he stole the election
from Stacy Abrams
that's right
what if Stacey Abrams was telling the
truth the whole time
Camp stole the election and then they
came to him and said we will destroy you
unless you help Biden win and then he
went uh oh
they were like we know what you did and
how you did it but we're gonna let it
slide as long as you do what we want
we'll let you be Governor but Biden wins
conspiracy theory
Let's uh here we go there was one about
Vivek
what do we have Christopher Daniel says
9th and 10th Amendment time it's always
it's 9th and Tenth Amendment time
healing says Tim have you ever tried raw
milk I tried it a couple months ago and
have been buying it ever since in fact I
had some earlier today as to die yeah it
was delicious you said it tasted like
cheese but I think that was the peach
yeah it had like uh it didn't it didn't
it had like a Cheesy in the back sides
of the tongue it didn't like give me
that salty cheese flavor I think that
was the peach really so it was like a
raw milk peach jam and uh so what we did
was went to a farm
and I bought pet milk and pet cream
it's not for human consumption right and
then we ate it uh
we I put it I put uh it was like one
third uh one part uh raw heavy cream
three parts milk and a tablespoon of
farm fresh peach jam I can only add a
scoop of naked whey protein I don't
think words can do justice how delicious
it was how natural I it was like filling
and I digested it rapidly it was so good
and that's just I mean the flavor itself
was special amazing it was crazy I felt
so good yeah Indescribable you know it
doesn't go bad too it just becomes
yogurt
which is crazy because pasteurized milk
goes bad just raw milk pasteurized milk
goes bad so quickly but raw milk will
just turn into yogurt really yep that's
good how do you make it sour cream
I have no idea because they're different
I was in Ukraine and I asked for sour
cream with my food and they brought out
yogurt and I looked at them like that's
clearly yogurt and then they were
insistent there's no difference
I was like I can tell you that sour
cream is like it's like tart and
delicious on everything and I would not
want to put fruit in my sour cream
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends and head over to
timcast.com click join us we need your
support as members as a member you'll
get access to the members only
uncensored show if you sign up at any
level for at least six months you get
access to submitting questions and
talking to us live on the air but if you
sign up instantly at least 25 or more
you can instantly submit questions and
talk to us in the members only portion
of the show so we do that as a basic
screening thing because we're trying to
avoid like weirdos extremists stalkers
and stuff like that so there has to be
some gate but uh do that and you can
follow the show at timcastirl everywhere
follow us on Instagram and um I think we
have I think we're on X somewhere
I think we have Clips you can follow me
personally on X or Twitter or whatever
at timcast Kingsley do you want to shout
anything out uh please follow me at
Kingsley Cortez on all the platforms and
then my organization I work for at am
renew CTR for Center please give us a
follow as well thanks
I am Phil that remains on X I am Phil
that remains official on Instagram the
band is All That Remains you can check
us out on Apple music Spotify Pandora
and the old YouTubes of course you're
wondering uh how to make sour cream
according to southernliving.com you need
whole milk cream and distilled white
vinegar or lemon juice really yeah go
find your recipes from there but when I
when I lactic acid and bacteria to a
combination of cream and milk and
letting it thicken and sour really
because when I buy sour cream the
ingredients are cultured cream is that
it those things make cultured cream so
that's what they call culture I think so
yeah interesting I'd love to make that
sounds simple well I love sauerkraut I'm
Ian Crossland thanks for coming catch
you guys later bye Kingsley good to see
you again good to see you bye everyone
and I am surge.com I am now on X it
changed my phone I'll call it X now yeah
finally
um yeah argue with me on there I just
hit 10 000 people which is crazy I don't
know why that I have 10 000 people to
follow me I don't really say much but
yeah cheers we will see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out